et ce que tu m'entends bien est-ce que
tout le monde m'entend bien d'ailleurs
que tout le monde
tu t'entends bien alors que c'est pas
on va bien on va bien se mettre parce
qu'on avait comment dire le setup
aujourd'hui un peu différent pour
poursuivre le match je peux te je peux
te partager l'écran directement sur
discord de Baki aussi si tu veux allez
vas-y
alors attends ça m'a décalé le truc mais
tu dois le voir
non non j'ai rien du tout là
moi j'ai rien du tout regarde bien
regarde bien sur discord kiki pas qui
est pas expérimenté sur discord
et après on pourra suivre le match en
paix
ok ok alors je me vois je vois pas non
c'est normal que tu me vois pas mais tu
dois voir mon écran
il va y avoir un endroit où tu peux ou
tu peux choper mon écran
on va laisser on va laisser maquiller
choper l'écran tranquillement il stresse
un peu la baquille je le sens je le sens
pas bien mais bon ça va tu rater là pour
le moment c'est que l'ouverture de la
première bah qui
ok alors attends même si je clique sur
en partage d'écran mais c'est en ne pas
déranger ouais mais je vais être en
partage d'écran mon baci ouais c'est ce
qui est écrit exactement
mais
malheureusement je vois que ma tête en
fait sur ton partage d'écran
ah tu dois pas être bien alors attends
je vais je vais essayer je vais essayer
de le remettre je vais essayer carrément
de mettre l'écran hop là je peux
t'envoyer je suis au bon endroit ouais
ouais non c'était sur la combe là tu
l'as là tu le vois peut-être là je vois
la flamme je vois ton logo et tu vas pas
là-bas
à regarder le stream ben voilà
ok allez c'est bon c'est parti on est
bon oh mais c'est parti sur une petite
c'est une petite taille manœuvre ça non
si je me trompe exactement bah qui c'est
la taille Manoff qui est qui est parti
et
déjà avant avant toute chose avant de se
lancer sur la partie ça donne du 79 21
bah qui niveau
niveau et encore c'est gentil pour c'est
gentil pour goocache
des joueurs tu as tout regarde c'est ça
c'est pas royal
alors je sais pas ce que ce que tu
penses de de cette évaluation ordinateur
est-ce que
c'est minimum c'est le minimum pour pour
Maxime
après ça dépend parce qu'il rentre il
rentre d'Inde là c'est ça exactement
il empêche le petit rock avec sa dame
manger 3 qui tape G7 F4 c'est pas mal
maintenant qui allait prendre trois
pions prend des trois
l'idée ça va être de jouer sur G6
foodéca qui prend les cases noires il
empêche complètement le rock
il est pas mal en plus ça ouvre la
colonne C il va jouer thorien la
pression des deux côtés pas de grand
rock c'est un peu comme une mauvaise
Razer pour pour goûter
ça a l'air pas mal ça a l'air pas mal il
y a peut-être des cavaliers des cinq
aussi d'ailleurs puis on prend puis on
prend maintenant c'est c'est chacun
c'est ça justement fous des quatre je
réfléchissais
je suis pas hyper fan du foot d'occasion
j'aurais préféré le tourcer un mais ok
il est 5 il envoie ouais c'est direct
mais quel menace cavalier B6 ceci
menace cette même cavalier prend puis on
prend fou prends on ferme la tour
d'ailleurs ouais ça menace tout en fait
ça a l'air un peu forcé ici mais
qu'est-ce qu'il veut sur des meuf 7
peut-être simplement tours c'est un
encore mettre la pression
un truc c'est que le jeu le cavalier il
sera enfin pour le moment il est pas
menacé tant qu'il y a le vis-à-vis et
Roy F7 ah ouais 7 c'est kb6 c'est
vraiment une boucherie
il prend mais pourquoi il prend il joue
au 5 il a pas de sacrifice 5 là ok si ça
passe il peut essayer de s'en sortir
comme ça ok mais j'ai l'impression quand
même
ouais on prend deux fois il va jouer roi
des 8 fous des 6 il va mettre les
barbelés comme ça
ok intéressant comme défense et si on
joue genre juste on recule et D4 pour
essayer de passer en force c'est la ça
c'est la simplicité c'est un peu mieux
pour les blancs après il faut ces trois
évidemment il y a toujours pas de faux
et 7 il est encore un tel pot à perdre
pour mettre le roi à l'abri sur du roi
F7 il y aurait du prix et des 4 ou prise
et tourin aux prises d'un F3 le roi au
centre
ces petites avantages mais là Maxime il
est en train de chercher ce que puis on
prend puis on prend fou prends ça peut
gagner a priori non comme ça première
vue
fais voir un niveau
de tête niveau tête ça raconte quoi bon
il réfléchit quoi
7 d'un projet 7.8 ouais peut-être il va
prendre il va craquer il va prendre
Maxime il a mis le maillot de la
processeur il aurait réussi de reposer
quand même deux trois bases d'entrée
important beau maillots
[Rires]
de Noël ouais bon
heureusement ça s'est senti mais tu
aurais dû le sentir dès la salle de
sport mon Baki il envoie il envoie le
fout proche et oui c'est pas pleut ici
ce que c'est bon je sais pas mais
pleutre
7 peut-être mais ouais 7 presque
l'impression qu'il peut y avoir du des 6
je sais pas je sais pas peut-être ouais
c'est peut-être un peu tout match non
cette prise en E5 après Maxime on sait
qu'il aime bien cliquer s'amuser ouais
après il y a peu de temps donc emblés ça
peut largement marcher mais c'est vrai
que et après puis on prend tout reprend
roi des 8 et puis on prend tout reprend
wave 7 je suis pas complètement sûr
d'ailleurs
il faut prendre tempo et choisir au
hasard une des deux cases
puis on prend ou dame prend donc
normalement il faut prendre et puis tu
vois parce qu'il y a aussi du dame prend
dans le
rangement
c'est ça l'idée au cas où en tout cas il
aurait pu prendre et voir quoi c'est ça
et ici il faut vite trouver entre roi
des trois début de MG5 et roi C7 ou au
F7 voilà comme ça
[Musique]
pour ça qu'avec la dame en E5 il y avait
dame F5 avec la Fourchette ah mais là
c'est
j'ai pas compris
simplement
si ça ça passe c'est magnifique
et c'est pour ça qu'il réfléchissait il
a trouvé cette idée de décises suivi
d'un F3 on voit que si on décide au lieu
de droit G8 si d'un prend D6 il faisait
quand même d'un mec F3 échec roi G8 et
ici tout F1 pourquoi je loupe là
voilà ça
j'ai du mal à comprendre les couilles
j'avais l'impression ah la Tour Eiffel
moi je sais pas ok compliqué en tout cas
la position a complètement tourné bah
qui ouais
un truc comme ça mais bon c'est horrible
c'est une pièce c'est une pièce de moins
pour rien
à trois
mais simplement b46
il aurait peut-être de jouer un petit un
petit fouet 3 tempo et gagner
tranquillement quoi que là il arrive ça
ça s'appelle une dame oh ça s'appelle
une dame gokashi 99 ans
il doit pas être bien quand même
[Rires]
bien ouais
elle était intéressante j'aurais bien
bien aimé voir un beau finis je veux
dire par bon écoute si on nous donne des
dames on les prend
ouais mais bon là pour l'intérêt du
match ça prend un coup on va suivre
Maxime tranquillement
mais bon
parce qu'il y avait tout refuide qui
gagnait
si vous vous souvenez de la position
avec la tour en 6 La Dame en F1 ok sur
DMC 2 il y avait peut-être du tourcé et
après une dame chez quelque part mais
peut-être que tour hf8 c'était pas mal
pour tout reprendre
c'est Punto au final on prend on sait
pas comment il a mis ce clip ou comment
il a mal placé sa pièce mais on prend
c'est un moi j'appelle ça va un punto et
c'est tout hein
un petit fou à 4
simplement moi après tout risque de
passer ici
j'aime pas trop dans le bêtises des deux
avec l'idée un peu plus qu'un requin ou
cavalier H4 éventuellement pas si mal
après Maxime c'est pas forcément c'est
c'est meilleur position
quand même mais il aime bien ouais non
remarque tu as raison en fait
il va faire quoi de massif ici peut-être
pour essayer de taper ouais voilà le
clouage ça c'est un bon coup il y a du
cavalier B6 en plus qui arrive donc il
va devoir jouer du fou
mais bon clairement il y a aucun
avantage blanc ici ouais fin j'aime bien
mais bon il faut il joue le coup que tu
as pas de Survival il va jouer non mais
il va jouer B6
Maxime commence par A4 c'est pas mal
aussi il menace à B A B dame prend un
ici les deux tours seraient bien plus
fort que la dame après on peut
s'attendre c'est prendre des cinq
blocage on sait jamais
[Rires]
de la première partie
la menace c'était AB oh ici à Bab ça va
prendre la colonne déjà et qui est B6
ouais fin mais ça va ça va pour les pour
les blancs il est pas il est peut-être
pas encore moins bien
parce que quand tu vois des matchs comme
ça bah qui je te coupe une petite
seconde mais ça donne rien envie de ça
donne envie de jouer de participer au
speechasse tu te dis ou non c'est
beaucoup trop fort pour moi parce que
bon là on a
c'est peut-être un des seuls joueurs
jouables je pense
pas beaucoup sur internet donc pour moi
c'est peut-être un des seuls joueurs
jouables ok
[Musique]
j'aurais trop peu de joueurs jouer
mais après tu vois un match contre un
DAQ un par un truc ok ça peut passer
encore ok c'est 5 pas mal il y a ces
deux fous là maximum il ouvre la
position il y a le cavalier H4 les
fourmis au placées les tours mieux
placés petit avantage de partout ainsi
cavalier 3 fois 5
on voit que toutes les pièces mineures
noires sont mieux placées que leurs
homologues E4 c'est juste un alors il
veut plus on prend ces quatre des cinq
c'est ça
pion puis on prend le 4 des 5 x 5
G4 peut-être mais ça sent pas très bon
il y a même du dame 6
des coups comme 4
là ça part si simple à réfuter
bizarrement j'ai envie de dire
5G4 d'un F6 on tape quand même le
cavalier H4 donc c'est pas
cavalier G2 seul coup cavalier E5
attention
pour protéger avec le fou hein à la fin
de la variante
F3 puis on prend F3 attaque la dame
attaque B1
tu as raison
donc on prend il est en train de
calculer ça mais c'est un calcul simple
en fait c'est pas si mauvais le CAT mais
le jouet en trois secondes ça s'expose
ben voilà il joue la réfutation
j'ai quatre d'amour G2 cavalier E5 JF
cavalier F3 échec ou un chien Dano 5
simplement c'est pas peut-être seule
réfutation mais facile ouais ouais ça
c'est à partir de 1300400 les gens ont
ce genre de ligne un Baki
c'est vrai que c'est une ligne
compliquée par rapport au coût E4 je
m'attendais à ce qui est des lignes plus
simples mais je l'ai trouvé quand même
peut-être la seule mais facile quoi et
au pire en plus si on donne une pièce
vous voyez ici il y a tellement de jeux
pour la loi
dans le chat qui nous écrit j'allais le
dire facile ouais c'est c'est le mot
quand on voit cette variante Baki qui
nous vient tout ça l'idée élémentaire
plus de mais à plus de 25 50 quasi elle
est morte
t'as pas plus dur quoi ça
son sacrifice de pièce était pas mal
dans la première mais après il a dû
louper un moment ouais ça c'est une fois
que tu vois des ventes comme ça bah qui
tu dis est-ce que on pourrait pas passer
au matin 2 ou on m'attend trois quoi un
peu monter en gamme quoi
c'est pour dire que ok c'est le niveau
en dessous
ça me fait marrer comment tu as trouvé
la ligne vite c'était drôle
en plus là très très marrant il y a dame
pro F5 ça va menacer tout raciste il va
le jouer Maxime vous allez voir ok oui
et c'est ça on voit que toutes les
pièces noires elles sont mieux placées
que les blancs
on voit que même les pièces lourdes
aussi pour le foubaki la case des quatre
rois je suis ton G6 cavalier le 5 d'un
F3 il y a tout là
ok il protège 4 bien joué fou je dois
bien jouer parce que ça évite justement
ce tour raciste
mais ça reste un pion elle est fousser
trop à peut-être ça joue encore un petit
peu chez les Indiens c'est peut-être
celui qui est le moins blitzer non chez
les jeunes là Google je dirais de toute
l'armada elle est rigide et les les
pragans etc c'est celui qui est enfin
comparativement à son niveau en langue
c'est peut-être celui qui est le moins
bizarre
le mot internet
il a plutôt bien joué les derniers coups
de défense et Maxime il choisit j'aimais
bien tout raciste
pour plus ou moins forcer il faut
prendre 4 mais ça c'est pas mal aussi
ça a été bien joué les derniers coups
mais ça reste ouais
ça reste un interventage allez dommage 5
jeux pour deux résultats non c'est un
perdable
quoi que alors il va y avoir l'idée de
D6 quand même
il va y avoir l'idée de 6 pour les
blancs
c'est pour ça qu'il a échangé les dames
j'aime pas trop les changer d'âmes
j'aimais bien damage 5 avec l'idée juste
d'attaquer tour j'ai vite fout des
quatre et Maxime décide que cette finale
est aussi notre avantage
je comprends sous des quatre ici ou tour
G4 ok
pour décaler mais bon il va réussir à
blinder
ouais j'aime pas trop les trois quatre
derniers coups de Maxime ça va pas
suffire ouais j'ai peur
balançant là qu'il a perdu on sent que
la force de ses pièces elle a été perdue
la colonne g après tour G2 la tour qui
est mis en défense
il a un peu loupé sur les deux trois
derniers coups après il a peut-être joué
un peu facile
c'est qui les occases vont revenir
bon attention il y a encore une 50 ans
contre 36 secondes c'est il est pas
sorti du bois
j'avais envie de dire Jordan mais non là
c'est dommage
il en est pas sorti son prénom c'est ça
c'est domara comment c'est dommage
il a bien les pièces c'est un bon joueur
quand même mais ouais c'est pas un
spécialiste ni de Blitz ni d'Internet
6 on tente on va aller la chercher quand
même celle-là
tu l'as déjà joué toi Google
je l'ai joué quand il avait 11 ans et
demi avec les Blancs et
il avait été Marlo il avait fait
s'annule j'avais pas été optimal
stratégiquement un peu moins bien joué
mais ok 11 ans et demi c'est un bon
résultat j'avais 27 15 quand même ouais
ouais ça va je te confirme c'est pas un
mauvais résultat ouais bon ok ça joue
bien là le roi Maxime qui
il aurait pas dû laisser faire ça ici à
tourger 7 ok mais tu reprends H2 ça
devrait gagner pour les Noirs ici est-ce
que c'est un intérêt
H5 c'était entre H5 ou tu reprends H2 il
choisit H5 d'abord c'est pas mal
ça pousse il a pas été très précis
Maxime sur trois quatre coups mais il
joue l'avance autant
ici même tout reprend H2O
pas à 100% mais quasi parce que tout
reprend tout reprend fou prend fou des 1
on voit que le Fou est complètement
fermé après roi des deux fois G3 le fou
sort pas du tout il va peut-être falloir
une petite précision des Noirs mais je
pense que tu reprends un jeu
il a calculé le jour vous voyez il
réfléchit au moment de dégâts et ici
foudéens
même H4 ou le fou et si le four à ce
mandat j'ai trop apprends en métro après
on va sortir avec B5
bien joué aussi
ok belle technique de Maxime et roissez
deux prochains coups le fou défend pas
du tout le pion B attention à pas se
prendre des 6 peut-être juste ici fou
des 6 encore une précision bien joué les
rois c'est trop abandon Roissy do
abondants
ok c'est solide côté Maxime
et malgré les fautes couleurs opposés
ici il y a deux pions d'avance il a joué
B5 se créer un pion passé B5 tout de
suite ça gagne aussi évidemment bien
joué belle technique il y a encore deux
trois coupes optimum de Maxime mais
c'est le début de match
c'est du 89%
il joue pas il joue pas du top 5 qui n'a
pas besoin de jouer absolument tous les
meilleurs coups
on sent quand même que Maxime il est il
est en bonne forme un meilleur forme que
l'année dernière
ouais après là il a trop de marge j'ai
l'impression
il va aller en car facile et à mon avis
ça va aller jusqu'en 2000 on sifflotant
et jockey après et ben je sais plus mais
je crois qu'il a du caca en demi
ok attention un coup comme dessin est-ce
que puis on prend cavalier prend ses
quatre
il va plutôt jouer le 5 Maxime en fait
il calcule la ed il jouait 5 bien joué
cavalier 4 et ici
il y a peut-être pas vraiment davantage
X3 suivi de kbdo je vous découle c'est
bien joué
ça reprend de ces safab il aime pas trop
quand on prend et qu'on laisse là on
redonne la case au pion ça y est pas fan
le Fab de ces trucs là c'est enferme le
fou G7
ça c'est pas du tout le coup de fable
c'est prendre des 4 mon Baki
malheureusement
ouais peut-être faut que j'ai quatre
c'était un peu mieux je sais pas mais il
faut que tu irais peut-être H3 fous.3 GF
oui oui
ça dépend c'est ça qui est en l'air
aussi donc c'est décédé c'est trop bien
joué
uleux
nos repères et nos champions baquis
quand même à jouer ce genre de position
maintenant il a une très bonne intuition
dans les structures françaises il a un
bon un très très bon feeling
ok les fous des trois bien joué faut pas
les changer tout FC1 je suis pas
complètement sûr
quand même ici on a pas envie bah qui
décides lui envoyer tout dans la tronche
là
alors c'est souvent l'idée souvent on
essaie de décaler la tour partout au 3
tour G3
l'idée de vlades qu'on a vu dans les
parties de 4/3 lagnau d'ailleurs mais
ici je suis pas sûr du Tour Eiffel je
suis pas sûr qu'il soit mieux qu'elle
était optimale dans les derniers coups
parce que on n'a pas le temps ici HKU G4
en plus
donc il nous manque un tempo la tour
elle est mal placée l'ancien j'imagine
kg 5 bien joué il provoque h6 il menace
a I provoque H6 ou 6 maintenant sur le 6
H4
puis on prend F4 et puis en français 8
et peut-être mais aussi à rien que H6
cavalier F3 on crée des faiblesses qui
sont intéressantes malgré le la perte de
tempo donc mais tu as raison aussi c'est
très intéressant sur HS GEOD
[Musique]
même si je suis pas sûr
en tout cas il va être obligé de le
calculer parce que si ça marche ça
marche
c'est cliquer sans calculer mon Baki il
a pris trois quatre secondes
détrompe-toi quand même
les deux options mais il était en train
de jouer en kg 5 et la calculer voilà
c'est pour ça ici il y a même du BK je
suis pas complètement sûr que ça soit
mieux pour les blancs mais bon alors
attends
il se met du E5 et du B4 par exemple H4
5 tout à fait 8 un très très bon coup là
c'est un très joli coup qui qui est
loupé il fait H4 quand même 5
et ici peut-être que ça va pour les
Noirs quoi que c'est complexe
les trois quatre derniers cours ont été
même toute la partie était plus au bonne
de son côté mais Maxime aussi c'est
toujours pas si facile à jouer il menace
faux F4 suivi de H5
et cette fois il peut essayer de rentrer
dans les fous de couleur opposés avec la
TAC encore une fois mais sans échanger
les dames
n'imagine du Tour peut-être que tour
aussi si si c'est pas mal avec les
décavaliers 5
l'idée blanche c'est fou F4 là il va te
faire foi F4 et H5 sur cavalier 5 vous
promet 5
qu'est-ce que j'ai loupé
F4 peut-être tourage 5 c'était l'idée
bien joué ok donc j'ai trois pas mal
mais c'est du coup pas mieux pour Maxime
s'il a pas cette idée de foi F4 quoi
qu'il la réitère ici mais tout aussi
semble un bon coup il réfléchit avec du
BK
s je sais pas
et là le fou il est bien placé pour
l'attaque avec H5
avait raison qu'il y avait peut-être du
fouet faim
non mais joue parfois F4 h5a5 c'est un
coût limite il avait du temps je pense
qu'il aurait dû réfléchir
j'aime pas trop son quoi 5 je pense
qu'il y avait du B4 qui était
intéressant ou du tout réussi j'ai
mentionné pour avoir quelques lieux 5
maintenant on voit que sur Tours H5
cavalier 5 tout prend le 5 tu reprends
le 5 à G avec une attaque fantastique
fou de couleur opposé dans c'est pour ça
qu'il fait tout rage 5 mais là on voit
le coup de G3 de Maxime très très bien
parce qu'ici même fou français 4 la tour
elle va être un peu loin alors quoi
qu'il faut prendre ces quatre il y a
dépenser 4 ça reste un bon coup tu auras
5 arrête tu rabais un simple peut-être
juste on se met en face et on s'enlève
tu vois on a perdu le tempo G3 et tout
va bien très bien parce que tu évites le
cavalier E5 tu tapes sur V5 aussi ouais
c'est ça peut être un petit coup de côté
là bon c'est sûr qu'il y pense hein
Maxime c'est pas un coup difficile il a
fait il a fait tu voyais pas la caméra
mais il a fait une petite grimace en
mode ouais facile tu vois
un bon coup mais après il reste du fouet
5 ici par exemple c'est ça reste une
position compliquée on en a pas encore
du tout parlé avant le début de cette
partie mais c'est une vraie balle de
break bah qu'il a un là il y a déjà 2-0
3-0 tu commences vraiment à bah déjà tu
t'es installé mais tu t'assieds tu
prends un sandwich à 3-0
il quand il a pris la dame je pense
qu'il a pris un sandwich
la partie elle est très intéressante là
quand même en elle-même
c'est
impressionnant Maxime il a
impressionnant il m'impressionne
mais les Indiens ils m'ont le détester à
force il va chez eux il est défonce et
il rejoue huitième de Pierre oui bon à
un moment donné il va quand même falloir
ralentir côté Maxime peut-être
si les balles chaque fois ça va pas bien
se passer
vous faites c'est bizarre non moi ça me
intéresser
de son roi après oui c'est du temps il
met le fou là dans la dame F3
directement je sais pas
mais ici qu'est-ce qui se passe sur tout
reprendre faut prends ces trois il veut
faut prendre aussi
c'est terrible pour Goo cash ice il se
fait maximer en fait j'ai l'impression
pour F5
peut-être à 4 après
dans la tronche c'est horrible
mais à 4 c'est un très joli coup bon
après ça a été un peu peut-être loupé
disons loupé par Maxime quand même cette
après il veut peut-être tout rêve 5 G4
aussi
mais j'ai quatre tours
[Rires]
après on va se poser des questions mais
bon
ça ça enfle le score après attention
Maxime qui est coutumier des petites
bases de régime quand c'est trop facile
donc il faut c'est quelque chose sur
lequel il voulait travailler il m'en a
il m'en a déjà eu parlé de dire ok quand
il faut que je sois plus tueur quoi
quand ça gagne il faut faire du carreau
quoi
sans repasser par un score je sais pas
qui est pas huit si c'est un moment
donné quoi
plus 4 ça va mais genre que ça repasse
pas par du plus en plus de quoi
on a encore une position intéressante
une carreau car 9 3 là qui tourne plutôt
bien j'imagine peut-être du E5 ici ou du
C5 petit rock d'abord je sais pas il va
choisir
il y a aussi des pro et 4 elle a
beaucoup de coups en 4 ça devient pas
mal maintenant que le cavalier Gien est
parti parce que si d e fe le cavalier G1
a plus la case naturelle F3 et on peut
jouer E5 et jouer contre un pion isolé
et enfermé un peu le fou des trois
des positions très dures à jouer pour
les blancs tu te souviens de si vous
vous souvenez de ma partie contre Chris
le premier coup que j'avais et ici sur
pion prend jusqu'à Vallier prend et on
voit qu'il va avoir un pion isolé actif
cavalier de B5 ok sur tyroc ici
une capture
il est facile un maximum il est facile
et réfléchi au bon moment il sort bien
des ouvertures là pour le moment il a
toute la panoplie
et puis avec le résultat elle a réussi
ça passe à l'étape prend
des deux à l'aide d'un B6
il va commencer à avoir du à 6 là en
plus pour chasser ce cheval oh là là là
il va être il va être long
pour vous cache ok oui alors que nous
nous délectons des victoires françaises
tu vois moi je dis toujours les matchs
de speechers quand ça va quand ça gagne
trop dans un sens c'est un peu long
autant quand c'est Maxime qui joue ok
c'est long c'est pas grave écoute on est
là tranquille on compte les points
surtout que je veux quand même les bons
coups tous les bons coups bon bah qui et
puis nous on est là on compte les points
dessus on est comme des comptables c'est
expert-comptable tu vois les on voit les
chèques qui rentrent on rentre on rentre
dans le tableau Excel tu regardes Punto
Punto
il est tranquille ou Maxime ça fait
plaisir de le voir
poser et poser les coups comme ça
j'ai envie de foudre simplement
et
si il y a
moi j'aime pas trop en F5 parce que
j'aime moins chez Maxime pour une fois
bien sûr H3 il va où ici je pense qu'il
veut torcer 8 et peut-être il va essayer
de combiner un truc avec du E3 je pense
je pensais qu'il se vend un truc un peu
c'est comme dans ces scandinaves là où
tu as le fou la tour en C8 à un moment
donné tu envoies du cavalier dessin que
3 tours C2 tu vois un truc un peu tout
de suite Maxime
j'aime pas comme
couper
ça peut être moi je sens je sens 1 2 3
qui arrive
sur GK tu vas faire fou aussi s'il fait
Fuge ici j'aime pas c'est pas la case du
fou mais faut aussi sauter c'était son
autre idée après je suis quand même pas
fan de fois F5 tu as donné les cases
c'est pas le mieux mais ok ça passe mais
ici je reprends le 6 d'un F4 et d'un E3
juste 3B
même G5 là c'est pas les meilleurs cases
pour les pièces je trouve que la croisée
4 j'aurais préféré un fou des 7 et après
H3 H5 même je suis très inquiet parce
qu'il joue comme moi
j'avais tous les coups là j'avais
absolument tous les coups maquillages et
ces quatre
on voit que ça va pas du tout bah qu'il
faut faut pas se voiler la face en fait
c'est sa pire pas
non le début était très bien jusqu'à ce
fouet
il a été peut-être trop il a trop voulu
de sa position alors qu'il était
peut-être pas beaucoup mieux mais
peut-être juste un peu plus agréable
pour lui il a senti que c'était il a
voulu jouer trop facile et là ouais
c'est moins clair
il a été facile
il était facile parce que après un coup
comme quand les blancs vont préparer G5
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire on n'a pas
envie d'échanger les quatre paires de
cavaliers
et on a pu vraiment de
bonne case là il y en a pas le temps de
faire B5 à 5b4 quoi
4 ou même du tournoi 4 ou du je sais pas
et si on fait du cavalier de dessin
ensuite on va avoir ok B5 qui tente
voilà ici quand on va tout échanger en
fait la structure blanche est meilleur
Ayou cavalier prend 4 je pense qu'il
devait jouer qui allait prendre des 5
il donne du jeu là le 4 cavalier Pro 4
tempo j'aime pas du tout tout d'un coup
ça se dit un fantastique pour Maxime à
jouer
terrible ce groupe
si tu peux vérifier alors dit je pense
que qui va aller prendre des cinq
c'était
égal quand même
tour ces quatre après truc comme ça
ok
menaces même du cavalier C3 du B33
genre au pire tu as aussi tout ce thème
là peut-être Dame des trois ici il fait
B3
B3 ouais de MC6
8 quand même ça ressemble à une qualité
si il va faire après en B4
ouais après
cavalier c'est 5 là ça doit aller mais
apprends mes 4 j'imagine du Tour B8 on
sent la grosse attaque l'arrivée après
apprend B4 ça a l'air
mais c'est totalement nécessaire parce
que à quatre tours 8 tours E1 vous avez
la petite tactique tu en prends 4.4 et
qui a eu ces trois échec et on récupère
la tour ça ferait une pièce de plus
et on a vu que Google quand il avait peu
de temps c'était dur ah mais c'est qui
est propre
bien joué aussi mieux que ton bébé
cavalier c'est 5 bien joué aussi ok coup
pour coup allez à 5 ici
position complexe
mais il y a du Dam G600 qui arrive pour
attaquer ici ici ici il y a beaucoup
beaucoup de jeux roi B2 bien joué à les
tourbé 2 i tour B8 ici pour jouer à 4
et tour B8 tours il y aurait d'un
Français 5 attention côté gouquet je
veux pas oublier qu'on peut pas décaler
la tour là-bas
il veut dame C3 je pense tour B8 dame C3
on imagine à 4 cavaliers prend un 4 ok
ça serait une position complexe
il récupère le matériel
ouais mais ok des bons coups quand même
de la part de Google là quelques bons
coups mais il se met mal au temps
attention parce que si la paire bon on
parle de score on parle de score mais il
va falloir qu'on compte bah qui je crois
que ça va faire 4 déjà
et par compter les Punto
ça fait mal
joli coup tu auras 8 H 6 bien joué
intermédiaires parce que là j'ai acheté
en français 5 et sinon on va jouer à G
et oui
c'est pour ça qu'après par exemple ici
damset 3G on est très content avec les
Noirs d'avoir acheté ça je pense G5 au
lieu de dame G6
couloir on a récupéré le pion de
meilleure manière et on garde Notre Dame
en plus en G6 pour taper ces deux donc
c'est tout bénef ouais parce que là il y
a plus d'attaque sur la colonne g et sur
les cases noires on a tout renforcé côté
Maxime allez tous deux
cinq d'un point à 5 EDF 4 est-ce qu'on
peut tenter quelque chose comme ça avec
peu de temps bon
si évidemment préparer un une
carabistouillette tu as un cavalier à 6
après Adams
ouais on sait pas il fait même pas 3 un
petit peu il brouille les pistes là avec
sondam F5 il va jouer de la F6 peut-être
pour
qui est intéressant aussi pour taper un
peu dans tous les sens fait de la magie
tu as pas 3
c'est bien joué là Maxime
un mauvais coup adverse pour e2d2 et là
il met une pression d'enfer allez F6 et
cavaliers F4 F6 pas sûr mais bon si ce
truc dommage c'est que ça coupe hein
il prend le matos un Maxime
c'est un peu risqué
de menace bientôt tours français 5 à les
cavaliers B4 ça a l'air
un coup parti un coup par là à 4 qui
donne juste un pion mais bon assez drôle
il va faire nul il joue gokuche il a
raison
qui veut dire 4 menace tour prend C5 il
va passer le tour prend ses seins qui
passe
alors attends
est-ce que c'est fini bah qui ou pas je
sais pas si c'est fini
ça fait 4-0 la marlouterie n'est jamais
finie ouais ça fait mal pour vous cash
qui dit quoi le Smart machin là Smart
chaise smarter chaise prédiction 95%
ouais bon c'était 99 il peut y avoir une
déco au côté Paris c'est ton jamais
c'est la seule chance à mon avis mes
données 5% de chance c'est quand même
beaucoup pour une déco parisienne après
c'est le smarter
maintenant que le score est fleuve
danubec
on aurait pu avoir quelques quelques
coups intéressants mais
tu es là pour chercher des prépas
c'est intéressant de voir des tapis dans
l'ombre mon maquis tapis dans l'ombre
allez céleste pas très bien il y a 6
c'est plutôt bien pour les Noirs ici qui
est des deux tours C8 j'imagine quoi que
fou G6 aussi ça fait mal
on laisse pas les cales 5
G6 mais peut-être cavalier 2 F3 c'est
dur d'analyser le début parce que ouais
justement là on est
on dit sur sur le stream de chess com
64% de la communauté de chaisescom avait
prévu une victoire de Google
c'était quasiment mieux pour les Noirs
ils rentrent dans une finale moins bien
mais bon
c'est ce qu'on appelle avoir la tête
sous l'eau pas qui
ciao ça va encore être une victoire de
Maxime
alors que c'était mieux pour les Noirs
je pense que Fuji c'était très
intéressant l'idée c'était de reprendre
en C6 avec le pion et pas d'une pièce
il commence par fouger 5 pas mal aussi
cavalier Yoka qui a tout reprend des
seins qui force j'aimais bien tour à
chemin faux-7 même avec l'idée fous des
4 plutôt mais bon ok il a pas besoin
d'être super précis là je pense Maxime
et il le sait en plus ça a l'air
vraiment dangereux ce truc là pour le
coup je pense que c'est moins fort que
toi mais bon parce que justement il a
une forte pièce en quatre il parlait de
thèmes pour la fougère
ça suffit quand même
ça suffit pour un train un tout petit
peu mieux mais elle sait pas optimum
mais là c'est ça le problème en fait du
match maintenant c'est que Maxime il va
plus chercher absolument les meilleurs
coups ça va être un peu embêtant pour
pour l'analyse justement
tour des sets pour tourger 7 tours j'ai
8 la tour underground
fermer c'est pas très joli quand même
il y avait j'imagine d'autres coups en
plus c'est à peu près par un F3 là bas
qui le cavalier des quatre qui arrive
visuellement terrible et aussi
l'objectif là pour Maxime enfin ce que
j'imagine c'est de réussir à rester
concentré à rester quand même propre le
plus longtemps possible
non mais pas facile
pour la demi-finale contre Caro est
monté en puissance
[Musique]
c'est directement une ou c'est un match
un quart de finale je crois contre le
victoire de Sarine Sarana mais je suis
pas sûr on va me dire dans le chat parce
que j'arrête pas de confondre de les
tableaux de de fearuja et de Maxime mais
ça doit être ça rime ouais au prochain
donc il sera favori sur le prochain
match je crois que ça arrive en fait
prise prise prise et qui va y aller
ah pardon encore oui après bon ici c'est
pleutre éclairé je crois que c'est juste
non mais je crois que c'est juste fini
je crois que c'est juste B5 fou c'est 5
torrent et ça va être ciao j'imagine
j'imaginaison mais là comme tu dis tu
reprends mes 7 la tour D1 est défendu
voilà c'est quoi ça c'est pas genre
Foussais 5 tours 8 tours 1 cavalier
aussi son échange tout en E7 et qui a
validé quatre à la fin pour tout
reprendre ici
voir tour à 7 tout est gagnant aussi
pousser cinq tours 8
mais ok ça me fume ta dans le le chat de
la partie tu as Franck Rutten qui est
qui vous cache rilini the win in this
time format quoi
ils experts même plus gagner le match
mais juste gagner une partie quoi
mais c'est trop ouais j'arrive pas à
comprendre ce qui se passe à la fin sur
cavalier des quatre je vois alors dit
qu'il s'emballe pas trop de notre côté
et vous trouvez le dernier coup on va
vous faire réfléchir un petit peu
maintenant parce que
alors l'ordi il avait une défense qui
était jolie d'ailleurs je vais la
montrer pour le public c'est cavaliers
F4
[Musique]
quel est le meilleur moyen de suivre
n'importe quel événement échiquier
surpris a du monde au tournoi des
candidats en passant par le speechesse
ou les title tussday
chase.com/aventure tous les plus grands
tournois d'échec il se déroule en
présence ciel ou en ligne vivez
comprenez en direct les parties des
meilleurs joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables bases
retrouvez toutes les infos essentielles
comme le programme les horaires des
rondes les prix les résultats les
comptes rendus quotidien les bio des
joueurs les règles des partages et plus
encore vous pouvez même participer à la
compétition au pronostiquant les
résultats pour tenter de gagner des
abonnements premium alors rendez-vous
dès maintenant sur chess.com/avent ou
c'est bien sur le site internet ou sur
nos applications iOS et Android pour
vivre votre passion comme nulle part
ailleurs
[Musique]
alors les amis
on est quasiment
de retour ça y est on est de retour à
et les gladiateurs aussi
tout le monde est de retour et voilà
c'est reparti avec maintenant 97% de
chances de victoire maximale et Maxime
qui envoie la Sicilienne nos conseils
avec Maxime sur Messenger et on a
demandé l'adoption qui on est gourmand
le 10 0
[Musique]
c'est pour ça qu'il est concentré là
sinon
très déjà trop facile est-ce que tu
penses que c'est faisable ou pas déjà
l'adoption est-ce que tu donnes plus de
chance d'une victoire dans le match de
gokash ou adoption
[Musique]
c'est fini mais plus de chance de
d'adoption ou pas
c'est pas ça va dépendre de comment je
sais pas si même si tu lui as parlé que
je suis pas sûr quoi qu'il essaye
vraiment
difficile adoption c'est 10 victoires
consécutives sans nul sans rien c'est
très difficile à réaliser même moi j'ai
réussi à survivre la dernière fois on a
fait un petit match avec Maxime il m'a
battu neuf et demi à un demi j'ai sauvé
mon demi-point bah qui je suis pas
laissé faire
mais là il va jouer un peu facile je
pense
quand même et puis bon c'est pas le but
de des échecs de gagner
le but des matchs c'est de gagner les
matchs c'est pour ça que il était bien
motivé au début et maintenant
ouais bah ça se voit tout de suite il va
pas gagner ça
le but de match c'est de gagner les
matchs c'est beau cette phrase
de réalisme mais c'est pas si sûr que si
la gagne pas celle-là non ouais parce
qu'il y a quand même cavalier de 5 tours
c'est un tour prend C1 cavalier prend
des cinq ta B2 après
[Musique]
normalement il y avait absolument aucune
chance là ok je viens de se rendre
compte qu'il a un petit souci quand même
il aimerait bien reprendre ces deux
trois derniers coups
cavaliers de D5 comment il veut cavalier
prend puis on prend B2
après c'est quand même
mais ça peut être très relou
sans aucune raison ça va être plutôt
blanc de défendre
et bien fous ces trois même il faut à
trois aussi évidemment parce que même si
la lui donne un peu d'attaque à Maxime
est-ce que vous êtes trois il peut avoir
du A3
ou 3 Damas 5 à B faut prendre B4 fois 6
suivi d'un des quatre quelque chose
comme ça ok il tient il tient
au Maxime va jouer simplement fou et ps6
ici et surtout reprend des quatre dames
A5
c'est plutôt Maxime qui va jouer le gain
s
toute la ligne à la fin sur damakas il y
a peut-être du fousser 3 encore
ici ça va être un tout petit peu plus
agréable pour les noirs
sur dame B3 on va pas jouer tour C8 à
cause de tour B8 mais on va jouer plutôt
roi G7 d'abord
mais là on est clairement clairement un
peu mieux
enfin on est mieux à quel point je ne
sais pas il fait à 5 j'aime moins parce
que ça laisse tomber vite j'avais pas
envie de laisser cet échange quoi qu'il
site tour B8 il veut d'abord ou H2 fouet
5 échecs sur G3 H4 c'est ce à quoi
j'étais en train de penser aussi pour
expliquer le H5
préfère voir j'essaie parce que de toute
façon on va devoir le jouer pour sortir
la tour
après H5 ça reste très normal là il va
jouer à G7 ok j'ai trois j'essaie
comme une perte de temps je trouve bon
j'ai 7 ici Maxime est-ce que justement
torcer là c'est tour B8 la menace après
roi G7
il y a pas d'échec et on peut choisir de
prendre des cinq ou à deux il le joue
finalement roi G7
on centrait mais tranquille mais là
c'est vrai que ça et on sent une petite
base de régime là quand il se frotte un
peu les yeux
c'est un peu facile quoi
mais salut à te mettre dans vos parties
en des coups comme roi G7 profilaxie
parce que là alors on peut se dire il y
a un pion passé pour les blancs mais en
fait le problème c'est que le roi est
faible et qu'on va rentrer avec toutes
les pièces on va menacer par exemple a 4
tours C8 des coups bateau disons à 4
tours C8 tourbé 5 dames échec ouais j'ai
deux tours C3 on voit que tout arrive
elle a tout tout est en train d'arriver
et surtout il y a la physionomie du
match aussi Étienne c'est-à-dire que
quand tu perds 5-0 que tu fais toujours
planter en tactique et que tu as ça à
défendre c'est pas facile
expliquer pourquoi cette position elle
est un peu moins bien c'est la position
du roi
mais si ça paraît bien mais d'un autre
côté quand la tour va arriver en C8 tu
seras peut-être obligé de revenir en C3
en E3 pour couvrir l'entrée en C1
j'imagine
et fou des quatre voilà il a trouvé
peut-être ici sur dama 3 il va avoir du
flou des 4
donc pas mal joué mais je me demande si
ici il y a pas de tour à l'huile d'un
point insiste on reprend un 6 à 4 et
Foussais 3
allez c'est ça qu'il faut trouver ici
Maxime après foot des quatre échecs il
faut prendre pour prendre 6 cette finale
elle est mieux c'est sûr
fou des quatre
j'arrive pas à voir pour le moment je te
cache pas
les têtes il veut jouer avec eux
c'est pas mal après
absolument jouer fous des quatre ici
même si ça reste mieux pour les Noirs un
peu
parce qu'après il faut prendre F6 on va
jouer au profit avec un super roi mais
quand même une structure moins bonne
donc
essayer de défendre MP3 pourquoi pas
d'âme certaines potes me poser comme
question pourquoi il rentre pas tout de
suite dans le dame c'est un tour C8 qui
est évident il y a une raison forcément
sinon il le jouerait et ce qui pense
peut-être à tour à 8
quand même peut-être
MP3 c'était vraiment kata il a dû
hésiter entre les deux
il a fait un petit roi la cam que il
loupe
il a raté ouais
il va mettre la dame
très faible H4 c'est pas mal aussi mais
H4 G4 peut-être que ça renforce d'un
côté ça affaiblit mais en même temps ça
renforce donc je sais pas voilà un petit
un petit tour à Singo aussi
bonjour bien joué dama
demain
très joli coup garde tout garde toutes
les menaces
mais j'aime beaucoup ton gamin je pense
que c'est le coup un coup Maxime
[Musique]
il a perdu l'intérêt Maxime
il a complètement perdu l'intérêt bon il
laisse fouber si sa 5 ouais c'est sûr
oh là là
il a perdu l'intérêt pour la partie et
oui non mais je voyais parce qu'il
jouait quand même plutôt bien et ok
comme tu vois
il a perdu l'intérêt totalement quoi
et ça ça pardonne pas
c'est normal
tu lui laisses l'avantage à Google s'il
a bien joué à un moment il va gagner si
tu lui poses des problèmes
continuellement comme il a fait Maxime
depuis le début du match
il arrive pas à tout résoudre mais c'est
là où ils sont très forts les joueurs
comme Maxime
il pose beaucoup de problèmes et ils
arrivent ils se laissent pas marcher
dessus
allez c'est aussi la force d'un Nakamura
tous les bons joueurs si tu leur laisses
l'avantage ils vont
ils vont ils vont pousser tu vois
celle-là il va la gagner malgré le fait
que ça soit entendu un truc j'écoute un
peu les podcasts de carwa dans ce moment
et il y a un truc hyper intéressant il
parle tu vois des joueurs entre
bah allez à partir de mon niveau en
blitz par exemple
et il dit ok un joueur de un tel niveau
en blitz qui soit gagnant contre
Nakamura ou moi en 25 30 coups il dit
bah ça m'étonne pas et il dit je vais
jamais penser que tu triches pour ça
parce qu'il me dit ça peut arriver et
c'est des joueurs complètement corrects
qui peuvent jouer des très bonnes séries
de coups il dit par contre là où je vais
être étonné c'est si réussi à gagner
sans problème parce qu'il y a en fait un
joueur du calibre de Maxime etc pour
convertir un avantage proprement c'est
hyper dur et il dit n'importe qui va
laisser des chances de revenir sauf top
mondial parce qu'il s'est impossible de
gagner proprement contre des tels que
nous
voilà après ça dépend des positions
mais c'est trop ok là c'est juste trop
en fait même des positions gagnantes il
arrive pas les c'est pour ça que je
parlais de ça et je disais Fabiano il
dit le plus difficile et là où tu chopes
un peu le les cheater c'est quand il dit
c'est pas quand ils ont obtient les
positions gagnantes c'est quand tu
réussis à convertir toujours trop enfin
trop souvent
il doit convertir en fait
il est déjà assez fort en Blix pour
convertir contre bon en fait non mais
comme on le voit
mais là on parle pas de on parle pas
d'un joueur lambda quoi on parle d'un
bonjour mais c'était juste pour rebondir
un peu tu vois sur sur la conversation
par rapport à ça oui ou voilà ou juste
il disait
[Musique]
si tu veux
je pense que les positions gagnantes
doit normalement les gagner
voilà quand on nous pose plein de
problèmes et quand ça reste pas clair
mais moi je parlais de ça par rapport
aux propres par rapport aux choses où tu
disais il pose beaucoup de problèmes et
c'était par rapport à ça aussi en fait
ils disaient ouais mais dans une
position gagnante en fait c'est dur de
conclure parce que les
poses ils posent quoi
mais là regarde comment il fait il va
rentrer avec Laurent E4 ouais c'était
sûr le fou en des six qui tient la case
B8 évidemment ou
elle a déjà faut prendre puis on prend
aussi il fait ça comme ça mais ce que
c'est pas déjà plus intéressant pour les
Noirs ça ouais F4 il va faire il fait
même pas G5 ok Maxime qui va échanger
je pensais qu'il allait tenter
l'adoption
il a complètement
il a gagné le match
pour les prochains
pas la date du match contre ça déjà ce
match là la date a été a été changée ça
devait pas être aujourd'hui ça devait
être hier Baki
est-ce que ça aurait changé une grand
chose je ne crois pas
c'est un Maxime plus fatigué hier non si
vous venez juste de rentrer
ouais non c'est sûr
contre Sarine ce sera une autre paire de
manches quand même
et Maxime devrait
avoir l'avantage surtout qui c'est un
peu réentraîné en belette en plus Maxime
dernièrement
il m'a vu il m'a vu un petit peu me
rapprocher donc il avoue lui remettre
une belle distance d'écart ce qu'il a
réussi à faire
relativement facilement qui
malheureusement pour moi
je me fais complètement marcher dessus
c'est trop
c'est déjà contre moi qu'il faut jouer
Kevin
il faudra qui
allez cavaliers
mais bon
faut acheter bon j'ai 6 fous des trois
cavaliers des quatre faut prendre des
quatre puis on prend des quatre même du
F4 peut-être pour blader blinder un peu
ces cases tous les trois bien joué
cavaliers
[Musique]
j'aime bien les blancs dans ces trucs là
la structure elle est catastrophique là
pour les Noirs
je vois pas l'intérêt de la structure
noire
il a pas de levier là il peut pas jouer
pour F4 il peut pas jouer pour 4 il va
jouer vite pour G6 tu auras G8 c'est
peut-être son seul plan mais du mal à
croire que ça passe parce qu'il va vite
jouer ses seins alors tout alors j'aime
pas trop j'aurais préféré avoir un chien
d'abord
et là surtout j'ai 6 c'est 5 pour G8 tu
vois il lui manque un petit tempo
j'aimais pas trop
comme tu disais on peut facile là Maxime
maison on le comprend complètement
un tour de bien joué pour aller mais
quoi que ça laisse du jeu un cavalier H5
non ouais il a laissé par rapport à
cavalier H5 cavalier F4 et ici sur G3 et
F4 fois 4 cavalier H5 voilà un coup
facile à la position elle redevient
complexe probablement quand même mieux
pour les blancs même G3 voilà bien joué
mais fouger 5 il faut prendre
ouais là il y a des idées pour les Noirs
il y a du F4 qui arrive il y a du tout
reprend G3 qui arrive il y a du cavalier
projet 3
quoique f4fgf
cavalier prend F4 ne marche pas ouais
intéressant on va qui c'est pour ça
qu'il réfléchit je pense
mais peut-être tu reprends G3
pardon HG cavalier projet 3 échec 3g2
cavaliers
ça ça ferait mal pas facile ici parce
que tour G2 il y a du F4 G4 F7 F5
F5 on aura peut-être un 4 à ce moment-là
il faut bien jouer
ou c'est pas facile là il faut top
mondial pour défendre avec les Blancs
s'il y a une défense je pense qu'il y a
parce que bon quand même
tu as dit quoi tourger deux F4 G4 F5 H4
non je pense pas par exemple fg3 même
H3 ouais peut-être complexe c'est dur là
j'ai du mal à penser que ça puisse
passer page 4 le roi est très faible
allez réfléchit au bon moment parce que
c'est pas facile s'il y a une défense
vous la trouvez sur F2
une taupe pas mal ça empêche les tours
plongés 3 et cavaliers aux deux
prix il a joué tellement vite ok
le tempo me paraît fou pourquoi si vite
après peut-être que tour e F2 c'était
très bien j'ai pas dormi donc je peux
pas vous dire
que tu le contrôle juste quand on a
ouais c'était les numéros
c'est un bon coup profil actif qui
empêche les tours projets
alors finalement pas si dur mais un bon
coup voilà là c'est là il a joué
vraiment un bon coup
il a blindé et maintenant il va
là on a eu une belle séquence de Maxime
ça fait plaisir
c'est des séquences comme ça qui va
devoir jouer s'il veut
du carreau
battre je sais pas mais déjà le titiller
moi j'ai une solution simple pour
batterie car vous c'est débrancher son
ordinateur on en parle plus c'est
radical Baki comme technique alors
Caroline il anticipe les F4 pour aller
en 4 avec le cavalier
mais bon F4 quand même EF qui est
cavalier E4
ici ouais je suis pas sûr que 4 ça soit
le meilleur peut-être qu'il pouvait
attendre un peu mais le prix
donc il fallait cliquer quelque chose
mais peut-être pas il y a quand même du
cavalier G4 peut-être qui peut réussir à
s'organiser donc il veut tourger 6 3 G8
ici
pour G6 qui a essayé de roi j'ai vu
c'est cavaliers 3
et ce qu'on peut faire cavaler ces deux
cahiers j'avais demandé ce qu'on peut
filer la cale en fait pour pour jouer
avec le cavalier
non mais c'est bien ce qu'il fait Maxime
je très très bien
comme depuis le début de semaine je
pense que ton GC soit jamais parce qu'il
faut pour aller cavalier G4 pour avoir
encore plus de
mordant sur le côté parce qu'ici juste
j'imagine qu'il va y avoir du B4 c'est 5
un moment quoi qu'il peut jouer pour eux
trois
ici je fais cavalier C2
E3 torins dame 4 prise 2 3 touches 2 il
y avait peut-être un truc un peu dans ce
style là
alors c'est quoi pourquoi
il y a un truc qui s'est mal passé là
il a plus beaucoup de temps c'est ça non
j'ai pas trouvé
[Musique]
de
peut-être prendre ici parce que j'ai un
peu loin du je vois bien la position
mais je vois pas trop le 15 une 15 pour
Maxime
je vais le prendre
téléphone
j'aurais les
chats en plus avec ouais
il s'est blindé
parti plus équilibrée depuis le retour
de la pause bien évidemment petite
baisse de régime compréhensible côté
français même si on est loin de la cata
ça reste extrêmement solide mais bon on
peut pas maintenir un niveau de jeu
optimal sur
3h30 fais penser à la coupe du monde de
rugby en ce moment il y a les moments
les temps forts et les temps faible
c'est pareil ici
c'est bien joué torcer un faux
finalement jouer pour ces cinq faut
ouvrir de l'autre côté parce qu'elle a
le droit c'est clairement Go cash qui
pousse
mais on peut tout récupérer à l'aile
dame surtout quand on a une bien
meilleure structure ici
oh que oui
je sais pas quoi faire ici Google
cavalier 2 Rois géant cavalier H3 même
roi et fin cavalier il serait
complètement à la rue là-bas
tourgé ici il fait roi G1 ok l'idée
c'était tout rage 6 il va jouer tour H6
quand même puis ça anticipe les
cavaliers F2 aussi roi géant
ouais mais surtout H6 H4
GH d'apprendre
pas sûr que ça passe il fait B6 pas mal
c'est bien quelle est par exemple si je
joue même B4 ici Maxime
je suis pas sûr qu'il en est alors sur
49 contre 28 maintenant
allez toi il fait tout rage 3
c'est un peu le coup de trop dans sa
menace juste rien non je comprends même
pas l'intérêt du coup en fait
c'est catastrophique oui
simplement damset 3 bam B1
dame
il veut quoi sur cette
attends mon bac ici je fais juste des 6
par exemple avec l'idée d'un projet de
pourquoi
il fait des six alors là je comprends
pas du tout
il va se faire mater Maxime
il va juste se faire mater pour la
catastrophique des six pourquoi
c'est horrible
ou pas je sais pas mais bon c'est
je pense que c'est trois ça avait l'air
tellement
le problème bakiss c'est qu'on a les
mêmes on a les mêmes coups
primordiaux
et pas d'un point il y avait pas il y
avait la fourchette qui va peut-être que
ça a gagné quand même
ça va perdre là
il a été catastrophique sur la fin la
maxime
ah ça gagne ça tombe côté
[Rires]
ah c'est trop franchement c'est trop
parce que c'est enfin il y a quand même
deux parties entre le Mystic et celle là
où ça pourrait faire quatre et demi deux
et demi et surtout toutes les parties ce
serait pas imméritée non plus quoi
qui donne le bâton pour se faire battre
mais parce que c'est pas facile au bon
moment le Tour Eiffel c'était très bien
joué et c'est les coups qu'il faut avoir
pour battre les meilleurs après le reste
c'est du détail c'est vraiment de
l'intérêt à la partie ou pas et là il a
perdu notre Maxime on m'écrit un truc
intéressant on écrit c'est pas une
boucherie c'est une boucherie
il y a des messages bah qu'il y a des
messages qui sont intéressants
je vais prendre c'est vrai que j'ai pas
trop le chat là
je préfère pas voir ce que vous écrivez
là sur ces parties
oui bon mais après il joue pas parce que
ça tue trop le suspense fou
de
c'est quand même c'est quand même des
scores qui sont très très sévères
quand on donne la dame en un coup dans
la première
et la conte
comment il a plus qualifier tu as dû le
dire mais
je n'en sais rien je pense qu'il s'est
qualifié à l'élo en fait allez l'OFI ou
un truc comme ça mais d'un autre côté
des pots n'étaient pas qualifiés donc je
sais pas pourquoi il est là
mais le sait-il lui-même en fait
parce que là dans le niveau il y a pas
une calife où il peut se qualifier et
puis en plus Maxime c'est pas la fin tu
vois il joue tête de série 1 contre 16
donc Maxime là il est pas tête de série
numéro 1 donc il joue contre un ok enfin
en fait c'est peut-être le pire joueur
du truc vous cache
mais après c'est pas grave non mais nous
on prend attends aussi côté Maxime
attention il y a quand même de la caille
à son jeu ça joue les Punto c'est ça ou
pas plus tu prends de points plus tu
prends de kayas attention
c'est peut-être 100 balles la partie
quand même
qui se dit ouais bon finalement j'étais
tombé de jouer le speech sans trop le
chat
mais je pense Google
en tout cas aujourd'hui
non c'est sûr
il y a quelques moments où il est pas
mauvais quoi mais
mais
enfin là dans ce format
après c'est un très bon joueur après il
a peut-être un petit passage à vide plus
global il a pas très bien joué
à domicile là en bride sans rapide
peut-être
prendre des cartes puis on prend le
cadre d'un match 5 Maxime ou cavalier le
5 aussi pas mal le F5 la maxime
un peu cuite la mentalement le match
mais bon c'est vrai que la partie
d'avant elle est fin kata certains
moments très bonne à d'autres mais bon
elle gagne alors qu'elle doit pas gagner
au bout d'un moment c'est sûr que c'est
mais là le F5 est capable parce que tu
laisses du Cavani au 5 qui a été joué
mais tu l'as dit qu'il allait prendre
des cadavres tu laisses tout en fait
c'est la partie c'est la partie a jetée
mais la partie a jetée parce que ouais
bon après
les plus solides
pour Maxime mais ici il manque tout est
mieux pour les blancs
pas complètement gagnant il un peu avec
le fouet 8 après
la prendre ici
comment parer ça Maxime
va le laisser faire
pas simple
c'est quoi ici faut G6 moi j'ai 8 puis
on prend le 6 fuj6 essayer de barbeliser
un peu comme ça
ou là puis on prend des cinq
[Musique]
j'aime pas ce coup
il y a du cavalier
enfin tout perdu il a perdu tout intérêt
ou là est-ce que c'est pour ça qui
arrive
ouais ouais
on a perdu Maxime là
temporairement
et encore et encore
c'est une tour nette de plus la cavalier
prend un 8 d'un point B2 attention il y
a la seule idée qu'elle prend vite d'un
prends B2 il faut jouer à vous de
trouver le bon coup blanc parce que il y
a la menace d'un point il y a aussi la
menace cavalier E2 échec celui d'un pro
et 5 mais après cavalier prend un but
d'apprendre B2 il y a un très bon coup
qu'il faut peut-être jouer tout de suite
non est-ce que tu pourrais commencer par
cavalier 2 quand même
alors cavalier prend à 8 d'un premier
deux il y a fou prendre des cartes qui
est très fort protéger un mais sur qui
on prend un tour e5a mais cavalier prend
8 peut-être qui va mieux deux échecs
c'est pour ça qu'il réfléchit mais
deux fous prends ces cinq échecs
3 G8 bon simplement tu reprends les deux
à la fin aussi
ça côté Maxime et c'est fou prendre des
cartes ici il y a dame prend des quatre
[Musique]
k ça pourrait faire 7 bac hein attention
on va trouver le bon coup
qui
va pas trouver il va tomber voilà il a
pas trouvé
quatre G8
c'est hyper chaud
alors il a pas trouvé mais il nous a pas
laissé le temps de trouver non plus
ça fait ça fait peur
par exemple
j'ai vite trouvé dans le 7
Maximin il est un peu fait de nimpla
elle a été
plus que kata mais bon il y a combien il
va pas chercher la caillasse
malheureusement
mais bon c'est de la petite caillasse
pour un tel
ouais petite mais caillasse quand même
bah qui
totalement passer
dommage de remettre du suspense dans un
truc où il y en a pas
absolument aucun suspense justement
c'est parfait est-ce qu'ils ont des prix
pour les segments non
au moins ça ça aurait pu en rajouter un
peu
ok allez une petite il évite la taille
manette avec B3 je le joue souvent en
title aussi
c'est pas si mal
intéressant mais la pression sur la
grande diagonale
et ici sur du E5 du aussi ce5 il y a
kx-3 celui qui est dessiné
D6 plutôt le bon coup vous cache elle
est juste fou j'ai deux petits robes
suivi de des quatre
on n'a pas trop envie j'imagine de
commencer par des Caps ici le jour je
préfère Fuger deux petits rocs
petites décape prise j'imagine damassin
échecs
[Musique]
prend des quatre en plus ouais il y a
Damas 5 il fera Dame des deux peut-être
d'un cran cavalier prend je sais pas
préfère éviter ces échanges normalement
mais c'est pas si mauvais pour les
blancs tu as raison Kevin Damas 5 dames
ça me prend à 5 qui va les prendre à 5
il doit y avoir après pas si clair il y
a encore fougé deux et compagnie bon il
a pris des quatre en premier
[Musique]
alors il y a pas un pion prend même puis
on prend ça arrive non
mieux pour le blanc c'est sûr
quel point
mais par principe cet échange qui allait
prendre des cartes et B5 c'est bizarre
ouais ils ont Fuji 2 c'est pas mal
j'aime bien
coups de Blitz puis on prend cavalier
prend
des bons coups de Blitz facile
c'est pour ça que j'aime pas B5 je sais
pas il y avait peut-être autre chose
pour les Noirs mais
sur les coussins voilà il y a toutes les
pièces qui rentrent
voir Dieu 5 quelque part au bon moment
une fois qu'on aura fait rock et qu'on
aura protégé le fou ouais mais rock
torcer un oui le vis-à-vis avec la dame
dessin avec la section prend des 5 merci
au revoir
merci au revoir
[Rires]
alors ça menace même pas cavaluer
pour deux raisons
un grand rock ah il fait tourner
ça c'est beau j'aime bien hk3 H2 très
bien joué
ça évite vraiment toutes les c'est un
coup de blitzer
et là je 4
regarde l'ordi propose un super cool je
trouve il propose damage 5 l'ordi
il veut se réorganiser il fait de la
mâche 5 écoute Maxime
parce qu'il y a un changement de tempo
dans la partie c'est-à-dire qu'il a joué
solide avant et tout d'un coup il te
glisse d'un match sans au passage c'est
bien joué hein ouais non c'est beaucoup
après je pense que je trouve H4 c'était
pas mal aussi mais il a raison là il
voit croit au 7 ça crée les cases
ça menace d'un H4
ok tourgey c'est maintenant
mais ce qu'on a très envie de faire ça
avec les blancs en blitz je sais pas
j'ai envie de faire H3
H2 et d'en finir
d'un match 4 3 8
ce qui va après s'intéresser je pense
que l'avantage est trop grand pour jouer
de cette façon après peut-être que c'est
sa manière aussi de trouver de
l'amusement bah qui
et de rester concentré
mais après c'est fort quand même il y a
pas de raison
le chat il y en a plein il m'amuse il
appelle Google
plus loin cache quoi
mais regardez l'idée de Maxime c'était
pas mal en fait il voulait pas ça gagne
tout de suite il voulait même pas Rocky
à la main il voulait développer sa tour
h par
parache4 H5 il poussait le Punto cette
fois-ci c'est la dernière
du temps pour jouer le moins possible
évitez les défaites supplémentaires ça
fait ça sur son point et demi
il a pas encore les doses puntos
vu c'est cool
il a pas les doigts encore
ouais c'est pas le match de l'année sur
lequel on tombe bah qui mais bon on
prend
on a quelques jolis coups de Maxime ça
fait plaisir on a Maxime quand même qui
revient fort après là le l'opposition
n'est pas assez mais il a fait combien
de points au tata style Blitz vous cache
je sais plus Maxime malheureusement il
était pas en grande forme après avoir
gagné
haut la main le tournoi rapide
ça fait c'est quand même
après bon faut dire que après trois
quatre bulles c'est aussi dur à jouer en
défense mais il est jeune normalement ok
tu dois quand même essayer de
je crois que la première la première
bulle lui a fait mal je pense tu
imagines les prochains les prochains
temps là quand tu vas jouer au Maxime
normal quoi c'est dur de pas se souvenir
quand même quoi
il se souviendra je pense tout
simplement bah qui
allez tours s'est vite mon petit
pression sur ces quatre ou à 6 pour
jouer avec B5 comme tout à l'heure mais
encore un placement de pièces incertain
du côté de Maxime et alors qui qui je
pense qu'il était presque mieux un
moment là le placement de pièces très
très incertain il y a peut-être même
rejouer fou des sets pour qu'il y ait
ici
est-ce que tu as vu le vlog alors bah
qui j'en profite pour te demander
j'espère que vous avez vu le vlog
de Düsseldorf le premier est-ce que tu
t'es vu
j'étais le premier à voir le blog
d'ailleurs j'ai été sorti depuis 8
minutes je l'ai pas vu en avant-première
mais j'étais dans les 500 ou 800
premiers à le voir
alors
ça ça retranscrit bien ce qui s'est
passé sur place ce que tu ressens
l'ambiance
pourquoi tu as perdu de Marc
c'est le pourquoi tu joues en version
2023 pourquoi tu as perdu quoi
c'est encore plus beau que pourquoi tu
joues non pourquoi tu perds
ça va je veux pas il le reste alors mais
ouais j'étais mais j'étais assez bien
parce qu'on a gagné quand même ce match
ouais placement plus qu'un certain là
les cases noires
il se fait enfermer la maxime
c'est surtout Sacha qui était pas bien
le gris chaud qui était pas bien quand
il était vraiment pas bien en plus
de mal il a eu beaucoup de mal à battre
un grand maître et juste avant c'est je
sais il me dit Mark il me dit mais
pourquoi
pourquoi il a pas encore gagné quoi
tu joues Sacha
attention on va pas se prendre un
cavalier dessin avec quelque part qui
prend le décédé ça a bien fait rire à ce
moment-là comment Sacha il est reparti
quoi
il était tout content
vraiment une équipe sympa
les enfants c'est toujours marrant un
bâti
[Musique]
encore dans la manière de parler c'est
très drôle
moi je trouve que c'est assez
bah non mais c'était comme si oui mais
c'était comme si il était vraiment dans
l'équipe oui mais je veux dire c'est
marrant
mais bon après c'est la PAP
c'est
un peu d'assurance aussi
c'est pour ça que je dis c'est marrant
un adulte il parle c'est pas c'est pas
que ça c'est pas que la jeune ça
jeunesse aussi
ça donne confiance quand même quand tu
gagnes ouais mais il y a le côté
bien au moins même moi c'est normal
en plus il est content
Maxime là qui joue sur ouais qui joue en
Dordogne sur place ces 8e et 7e il
améliore quand même pas à pas ses pièces
on imagine que la position c'était pire
il y a trois quatre minutes
là-bas avec ses grands sabots
peut-être cavalier ceci suivi
il va finir par le jouer
ok le cavalier prend le 5
non bon il le joue pas bah tant mieux et
maintenant comme tu dis roadset il faut
H6 mais je pense que vraiment ça que ça
faisait très mal
qui a eu des quatre mais où il veut
aller où en fait il veut jouer 4 il veut
quoi
mais ça va pas ouais l'intuition elle va
pas du tout côté de domeramu
quand ça enchaîne mal comme ça c'est
tellement dur surtout que tu sais qui te
reste encore une heure et demie derrière
c'est démoralisant
que tu m'as poussé à jouer bah voilà
c'est exactement la même chose quand ça
se passe mal c'est
sauf que l'Arena tu peux l'arrêter ouais
puis là il va perdre il tourne j'ai 8 il
va se faire mater en Maxime qui remet
les pièces
il va devoir trouver un moyen quand même
ici de quand il va jouer G4 il va devoir
éviter la fermeture d'opposition par HG
à GF4
et fede et jouer le clouage c'est
terrible on peut pas commencer par rager
côté chez là c'est important c'est
n'importe quoi
dans l'arena tu l'as dit juste avant un
moment donné tu es en tarif plus
la première ou deuxième partie quand
même oui mais je veux dire là maintenant
il en est dans à l'état où il peut plus
en fait c'est tout
non mais ça je suis d'accord avec toi il
peut plus jouer il peut plus en fait
qui fait une déco
c'est sa meilleure chance en plus il
gagne de la caillasse en étant déco là
si le score reste à
à 8,5
du coup c'est horrible
4 projets et il y a pas de cavaliers
pour investi c'est chèque moi j'aime
bien compter ça va faire plus suite
et encore c'est bien payé c'est bien
payé
dans une quand même c'est payé
normalement
c'est payé normalement bac
mais ouais c'est plus sept c'est
beaucoup
il y a tout en fait
attention parce que tu joues quoi
et non pas ed qui allait prendre un cap
des Français pas aussi tout reprendre
géométrie de partout des fourchettes
royales il y a tout qui gagne c'est
écœurant pour pour cash
et pour nous aussi ouais en vrai là
enfin évidemment on est content que
Maxime gagne mais normalement là le
match devrait terminer il devrait pas y
avoir encore deux heures de spectacle au
niveau de jeu
est-ce qu'on peut dire que c'est le
cirque Pinder côté goût cash est-ce que
c'est le moment de sortir l'expression
bah qui
cirque Pinder j'attends l'expression
c'est ça me fout
elle est pas méchante
c'est Pinder
un poids et fou F4 qui va arriver
ça marche en plus ouais c'est horrible
bah là il y a bientôt les cracheurs de
feu qui vont arriver
sur la caméra
là c'est Maxime et bien tant que tu as
les jongleurs les cracheurs de feu après
la pause regarde il boit un peu d'eau
si on fait une petite pause et on aura
le temps de discuter après parce que là
c'est
c'est tout de suite vous voulez streamer
des échecs comme vos créateurs préférés
tels que Blist stream Naka ou les soeurs
le programme de Community streamer de
chains.com est fait pour vous débutant
dans le streaming ou déjà expérimenté
peu importe c'est le moyen idéal pour
élargir votre audience en connectant
votre compte à cheese.com et profiter de
la visibilité offerte et d'autres
plateforme de jeu il vous suffit de
relier votre compte à
cheese.com/ettings
mettre échec comme catégorie sur twitch
et commencer à streamer
d'une expérience sans publicité sur
chaise.com et apparaître et dans notre
liste de streamer en direct votre profil
affichera votre stream twitch qui sera
aussi mis en avant durant vos parties
offert utiliser la commande community
streamer dans le chat et faites grossir
votre audience sans plus attendre
[Musique]
alors mon bac qui on est de retour
Maxime
qui est de retour aussi
est-ce qu'on ferait pas jouer est-ce
qu'on le ferait pas jouer le oui
[Rires]
ça reprend dans une minute 35 et Maxime
facile
je crois que c'est le mot du jour qui
aujourd'hui facile
tu veux dire que je vais gagner de téter
facile à mon avis tu vas tu vas survoler
tu vas survoler va qui en tout cas ça
t'inspire non ce match
bon et non pas vraiment en fait
bon tu te dis quand même c'est comme ça
je comprends ce que tu disais il y a des
années là on tombe vraiment sur un match
après ça va c'est cool comme c'est
Maxime c'est cool moi j'en ai commenté
une quantité de matchs comme ça mon
bâtiment pour moi
assez spectaculaire et je me souviens
d'un beau match que tu avais commenté
avec Maxime d'ailleurs
alors c'était lequel je suis dans les
commentaires plusieurs
Magnus contre quelqu'un qui suit un
petit peu
j'avais commenté un Magnus sparades avec
Maxime exactement
ça a dû être catastrophique ouais ouais
qu'est-ce que tu veux après c'est dur
hein si ils sont forts
ou faut vraiment
quand c'est chaud c'est toujours hyper
intéressant mais bon il y a des joueurs
qui sont au dessus du lot comme comme
notamment Naka Naka Maxime Magnus
ouais
un match bientôt c'est quoi c'est
Fabiano contre Caro
même si Fabiano il joue quand même pas
mal maintenant même ça
ikaro dès qu'il joue pas mal
d'ailleurs qu'il est posé énormément de
problèmes et failles perdre il avait
joué ça est fini à égalité contreding il
se passe quoi avec dingue
il devait jouer et puis finalement il
jouera pas il était remplacé par Yann
c'est pour le 5e field c'est ça ou non
disparu non je crois que je crois qu'il
avait vraiment enfin je pense que il en
a vraiment marre de José chacun dit
ouais mais il a le droit hein qu'est-ce
que tu veux
c'est bizarre quand même
non mais je suis d'accord avec toi mais
je veux dire je peux je peux aussi le
comprendre
il a annoncé mais bon est-ce que mon
corps c'est le speechestre
pour le moment
mais bon c'est bizarre parce que même
quoi qu'il arrive il aurait pu jouer
comme ça
quel petit Dame des trois
très dur à les échecs quant à moins
l'envie l'envie d'avoir envie
c'est quand même un truc facile ou au
pire bon ouais il voulait peut-être pas
être ridicule
du monde il a dit je vais me faire
déchirer
c'est dur de se faire déchirer
je comprends ça peut être long et tout
ouais
qui se met la main devant les yeux
parce que c'est moi qui joue un coup
pareil non MSI
est-ce que on peut tenter un fou B6
cavalier 4
il faut baisser de la chance après tout
reprend B6 qui
cavalier français 8 cavalier prend un
chien et encore fou prend à 6 qui avait
project trois fous B7 on peut imaginer
que ça joue encore mais
c'est de la chance cavalier A4 sinon
c'était abandon
évidemment s'il se fait casser la
structure cavalier prend trop c'est fini
tôt ok bon ici F3
ça va un peu mieux mais F3 ouais F3 ça
va ça va et là il a de la chance
c'était quand même le coup en tout cas
c'est ce que j'aurais tenté mais ok
de cette F3 je sais même pas si ça va
être mieux pour les noirs
c'est
ça se retourne mal mais c'est souvent ça
quand tu commences à être dominer et
tout
il veut juste
pas comme ça donnera un mot
j'envoie d'autres options en fait il y
aura pas même fou prend à 6 après
il veut pas
huit mais bon on pourra peut-être
imaginer un X 7 force et tour à 8
revenir avec vous le timing est assez
catastrophique quoi il voulait ça
ça part juste
on est au moment où j'aime pas trop dans
le speech ou t'as pas tu as pas envie
d'accabler le joueur dans le sens où bon
bah tu comprends qu'il arrive juste plus
à jouer et d'un autre côté les parties
deviennent vraiment inintéressante quoi
non mais fous de cette tempo quand même
enfin tu peux réfléchir un peu tu vois
enfin je veux bien
non non je sais mais c'était juste pour
pour te dire c'est un peu le moment du
coup que je trouve un peu compliqué
parce qu'on comprend que
en vrai il a juste envie de se barrer
quoi
je mets le maximum aussi les deux ouais
et c'est ça que j'aime dans le speech
c'est qu'en fait on arrive à un moment
où tout le monde a envie de se barrer en
fait les spectateurs les commentateurs
et les joueurs là tu as tout le monde
qui se dit ouais bah c'est
c'est le moment en fait tu peux quand
même te battre un peu
c'est cette intermédiaire là
à 7
ça tient encore mais bon tu reprends H7
quand même
faire deux pions
c'est mignon j'aime bien
après voilà
[Rires]
c'est le pauvre
pour Maxime je sais même pas si j'ai
envie de dire le pauvre
ah tu as quand même envie mais
[Rires]
ok c'est hyper autant si donne une dame
d'accord mais là elle est cool
un joli fougy
[Musique]
tranquillement il faut acheter
tout prend F7
mais là ça va
c'est encore pire non non
univers impitoyable Baki
ça nous rajeunit pas mon baci Dallas
mais l'univers est un pitoyable en tout
cas
comme moi mais non
allez ferme moi cette fenêtre OK
vous avez
l'insupportable et prochain c'est fou B3
et A3 c'est trop
il va faire
Maxime c'est peut-être un peu embêté
mais bon
mais il y a peut-être la récupérer quand
même
il y a beaucoup de beaucoup de pions ici
tu enchaînement réussi finalement un
petit enchaînement réussi au FC Tours 5
il y a pas de G5 et il garde la pièce de
plus
Maxime qui en a beaucoup trop fait ouais
mais ok ça il y a eu quelques bons coups
là à côté adverse finalement on va en
voir plus souvent
est-ce que ça va suffire
il va pas la perdre en tout cas
il va même la gagner incroyable
incroyable quel dommage
est devenu tellement décousu mais il a
quand même fait pour cette fois il a
fait une quinzaine de coups la quasi
parfait enfin
dans ma revue ouais il a enfin
allez s'il peut essayer d'enchaîner pour
qu'on ait après deux trois parties
intéressantes
toi tu es quand même un peu pour
l'intérêt du match quoi
tu veux quand même voir deux trois
belles parties d'échec oui parce que
sinon on regarde aussi non
mais c'est dur de commenter quand si les
joueurs s'en foutent
c'est dur
parce que leur coûts n'ont pas de sens
pas un peu comme la dernière partie
c'est ça
donc il nous faut quand même un peu
d'intérêt le seul moyen d'avoir un peu
d'intérêt c'est que Google se rejoint un
peu mieux comme il a fait sur les 15
derniers coups et que Maxime
de reprendre
le dessus voilà la partie j'ai envie de
te dire elle est de nouveau quand même
assez
décousu hein celle-là elle fait pas
beaucoup de sens pour l'instant
elle sait pas beaucoup de sens pour
l'instant
bon les coups de Maxime sont plutôt bons
son idée ça va être de jouer contre le
faux F4
mais là ok cavalier Descartes c'est
plutôt pas mal parce que si cavalier
prend des quatre C prend des quatre il y
a le cavalier E4 qui aurait pu vraiment
de case
ok cavalier des quatre tours là c'est
deux pour deux bons coups de de grand
maître
même enfin de grand maître à 2016
parce que ça pouvait être vite moins
bien pour les blancs et là c'est deux
coups là ok ça renforce un peu le centre
et ça met un peu d'attaque c'est ça pose
des questions pratiques mais damashcade
bien joué de côté Maxime provoque G3
et coupe du coup les entrées de la tour
sur la troisième
ok bien joué H4 allez obliger menace du
G5 avec Maxime attention
j'aime pas trop pourquoi pas H4
et il a pas fait H4
les coups à la main là qui sont pas
joués à côté
côté
surprenant parfois que vous cache
en fait
que ça serait pas qu'il aurait pas un
frère
tu veux dire que ce serait peut-être il
y a du dommage à jouer et peut-être du
ouais ouais je comprends
c'est pas
on sait pas
on sait jamais qui avec avec eux
les échecs de haut niveau c'est aussi
beaucoup ça des gens qui ont des noms
qui se prononcent bizarrement
et on l'a vu avec toi il y en a qui
disent bah crotte j'ai j'ai pu entendre
et oui j'ai pu entendre
il faut être quelques-uns pour pouvoir
cliquer et oui c'est ta botte secrète le
Bacrot
c'est les Russes qui t'appelle comme ça
non il t'appelle pas croire
faut pas être tout seul est-ce qu'on
aurait pu faire dames prends des cartes
et tout reprend F4 pour le spectacle ou
c'était beaucoup trop
voilà c'est un combat case noire contre
case blanche et Maxime est pas favori à
ce petit jeu là
alors là ça va quand même
j'ai une difficulté en bouteille d'eau
mais je la récupérerai à la pose Baki
regarde tous les pions
c'est un peu déçu s'il arrive à mettre
un cavalier en F3 puis on le Cat et puis
on des 4
faire G4 pour cavalier prend un F2
en premier
[Musique]
une boucherie c'est ça une boucherie
ouais
même Maxime il arrive plus à regarder
les parties ouais c'est difficile
je me demande si elle essaye pas de
faire un chantier prend F2 tu vois un
truc comme ça très
pourra peut-être commencer avec
pas un pion en moins un truc comme ça
elle est partie
il avait pas non plus il est quarté les
yeux là
il a fait il a donné une pièce
ça marche absolument pas c'est terrible
c'est
pas si bête quand même
oui mais c'est vraiment au hasard là il
envoie
ce que je peux le mettre
complètement au hasard
il y a peut-être fou acheter
ça peut être un joli coup parce qu'avec
l'idée pion prend des quatre ici
ah mais non il y avait tout alors
attention attention
c'était fini tout à l'heure
quelque chose en réalité ouais il menace
et sur dame G6 il va prendre en D1
simplement vous pouvez F4
il y a pas puis on prend C3 bizarre il
pouvait jouer dame prendre un dame prend
des quatre simplement beaucoup d'avant
avec deux pions d'avance et abandon
pas un beau match franchement
vraiment des mauvaises parties de Google
OK
et du coup du coup on a perdu Maxime
face au mauvais coup adverse
c'est un défaut récurrent de Maxime et
c'est pas le seul à avoir ce défaut
c'est
dame prend F4
non mais c'est trop même moi j'ai en
fait
il y a pas d'échec
c'est trop bah qui c'est trop c'est
beaucoup trop
mais il joue vraiment jamais sur chaise
comme
vous cache
je vais te dire ça
il a 330
[Musique]
plus ou moins normal
ok le niveau est vraiment très faible
même si Maxime poserait problème mais ok
ouais ça paraît réel d'être 27 70 ans et
jouer comme ça en fait
c'est pas possible
mais il joue quand même des coups assez
embêtant
même si là il joue un peu au hasard ok
c'est quand même il y a des coups
bon
après il est peut-être juste malade
ça c'est un genre de jolie coup je sais
pas si il faut faire attention qu'il y a
pas des cavaliers froid quelque part
puis on prend des quatre d'apprendre des
quatre et f3gf ça me prend H3 F4 n'a pas
l'impression qu'il y a quelque chose et
du coup ça lui plaît ça permet à Maxime
de gagner du temps sur le cavalier et en
même temps d'améliorer sa structure et
ça c'est un joli coup
ouais je après faut pas sous-estimer
c'est le côté qui se enchaînement tu
sais dans des matchs comme ça
ça se passe mal
complexe
complexe complexe
les deux fous
essayer d'échanger quelques tours
ici ça sera peut-être pas si mal à un
moment d'envoyer un projet 6 aussi une
des rares fois où on peut donner le fou
mais pas si bien placé
c'est aussi parce que tu as l'avantage
matériel
ouais et puis l'adversaire là il a quand
même des sur cases noires et sur l'aile
endroit il a quand même quelques pièces
de plus on a quand même le foot des 6
dames G5
versus que la dame F3 si tu mets le fou
en G3 peut-être qu'on a pas du tout
envie de jouer du projet 6 mais là c'est
pas loin de vouloir donner le fou pour
et voilà et il le donne tu vois
en plus Adam c'est trois
là pour le coup après damocet vous avez
des 6
un an pas du tout prendre
OK
Maxime qui devient méchant dans cette
partie
c'est un peu trop les dernières parties
quand même il fallait un moment donné
rappeler les bases comme dirait Maxime
alors ne pas jouer Dame des 5 rois H8 D7
il y a peut-être tour e prend F2 mais
même juste pour reprendre F2 dans
tout de suite ouais c'est quand même
mieux surtout des deux il veut quoi il
veut peut-être
le plus simple c'est abandon la descente
bien joué
bonne conversion cette fois une partie
solide de Maxime là même si elle était
facile quand même solide on peut pas
dire le contraire une bonne partie pour
Aden
après il se devait un Maxime de faire
une bonne game ouais parce qu'avant
c'était il était quand même dans un
engrenage ouais et surtout reprend bien
il y a un super coup enfin super cool un
coup de rôle c'était d'un point et fuite
il a peut-être pas le faire tout de
suite il va peut-être juste jouer de la
mosette
c'était pas mal aussi sur les prisons F2
il y avait soit dame prend fuite soit
David
finir cette partie proprement
tour reprend tour F3 F2 il veut débuter
échec
tu reprends derrière c'est ce que je
voulais me faire marcher tout à l'heure
et ça marche maintenant
inarrêtable très jolie dame B4 on vient
d'un point de vue allez belle partie de
Maxime et c'est le 10e point
dixième pas 10e victoire parce qu'il est
nul mais dixième point Maxime qui
repasse tranquillement à plus 7
c'est l'écart stabilisé maintenant qui
tel un Ploton du Tour de France qui
contrôle un échappé il garde ses
distances là il a fait une bonne game
tout à l'heure
jusqu'au bout qui jusqu'au bout
allez fous c'était pas mal ce que tu as
fait tout à l'heure
ok
ce qui peut faire ici
simplement un petit roc pourquoi pas
voilà c'est jouer et 5 ou 7 même
pas sûr du dame c'est 7 mais ok
ça a l'air d'aller tranquillement
qui a été Satis il veut juste virer le
cavaliers de 5
il laisse un peu du cavalier H5 je sais
pas qui peut venir
je sais pas en pratique ouais ça a l'air
d'aller
simplement deux ok il va faire quoi tu
auras 8 il veut être 6 il veut pas
laisser le pion aussi en l'air et là il
veut être 6
[Musique]
je suis pas sûr mais moi c'est solide
D7 prend le 5 et il protège G7 via la
dame C7
un kf5 c'était le coup il fallait
il veut F6 ici il veut protéger G7 avec
la dame
allez faut jouer F6 qui est projet 7
mgk-38 fois 6
toujours le cavalier prend le 5 et une
prothèse cette case G7 ok prise
d'apprendre des 6 peut-être il fait un
G4 cavalier prend
OK
des coups solides côté gouquettes et
côté Maxime je partais d'autre
qu'est-ce qui veut sur X6 ici Maxime
peut-être
je crois sur X6 attention sur du roi
Swift je me demande s'il veut pas E5
Baki
qu'est-ce que ça peut marcher peut-être
peut-être raison Kevin ici pour 3
on aurait aimé avoir ce genre de partie
en début de match
ouais là maintenant la saveur est un peu
la partie est pas mauvaise quand même
des deux côtés cette fois
c'est bien
non ça joue bien à côté Maxime et faire
f54 non ah F5 il y a pion pro E5 pardon
pas laisser les cavaliers 5
parce que 4 sur les cavaliers F5 et F5
comme tu dis il y a des 35 le coin
intermédiaire important donc il fait
rois
et ici de fe et probablement ces quatre
jouets
sans C4
sur C4 Baki
c'est pas mal aussi
mais ici à dames F3 donc dame c'est 5
il veut peut-être sur dame C5 le couple
B4
je sais pas
que tout F4 ok dame C8
c'est bien joué de la part de Maxime il
se place
ouais la partie Est de plutôt bonne
qualité
7 H6 aussi un jour attention
pour le moment
donc meilleure structure pour les Noirs
mais le roi assez faible et là il y a
pas tout reprendre
très très bizarre parce que ça
affaiblit le roi et sa décale les tours
mais d'un autre côté
les plus le roi noir que le roi blanc
avec le cavalier en G3 qui contrôle la
chambre
j'aime pas du tout
mais non c'était bizarre complètement au
hasard ouais ça a complètement ouvert le
roi noir et bon ça peut être intéressant
si on menace du Tour à chiens si on
force du roi et fin mais face au
cavaliers G3 moins qui est Dieu 4 ici
pour tout rachat d'un match d'eau d'un
proche
pourquoi tu aurais fuite et de la même
quasiment
bizarre cette partie
bizarre bah qui
faut calculer il a joué un peu au hasard
ce H6 d'un point H6 en fait ça a
beaucoup plus cette faiblesse on voit
que le roi adverse
si on l'appellera le match au hasard je
pense
ah ouais mais c'est c'est là que tu
regrettes un peu quand même de pas avoir
d'essai ou les joueurs sont obligés de
se remettre et de remettre le goût de
chauffe
et oui
l'intérêt du système 7 de forcer
à jouer
c'est comme ça qui nous ne faisons pas
les règles
à fortiori vous
on prend les cases là mon Maxime
que c'est vraiment bien pour les blancs
ici d'un point cavalier prend pour jouer
F5 ou des 5
c'est pas
la tête faire Dame des deux
pour avoir
j'imagine même F5 EFD 5
avec du jeu quand même
donc ça ok ouais B5 faut baisser c'est
pas mieux pour les blancs aussi
des meilleures pièces et il pourra pas
éviter F5 ou des 5
on a perdu des tempos quand même je
trouve après peut-être je me trompe
grand Rocket 6 peut-être tu te trompes
quelque chose comme ça tu te trompes
quand même rarement un qui
peut-être qu'ici
tours
après ici prise tout rachat il peut y
avoir un problème de
menace souffre en V5 là
il doit jouer F4 obligé
EF il y a une découverte dans ce cadre
notamment quand G4
mais oui il y a tout qui gagne
mais tout simplement fou ces quatre
projets 8 la plus simple découverte
facile
ici des six juste fou des trois
imote clic au hasard
une petite un petit clic au hasard un
petit peu
je crois que c'est plus le
plots ici
c'est plus la question qu'on se pose qui
joue complètement au hasard aussi on
peut pas le
on peut pas lui retirer ça
à B4 tu vois il est un peu réfléchi un
coup un peu sensé
mais voilà la case blanche là ouh là là
le développement
assise qui va tomber ça va être une
nouvelle partie
sans grand intérêt
il force pas Maxime à se sublimer dans
ce match
il ne force pas Maxime à se sublimer
juste tour des 6 ici
et
les puntos partout
au minimum ce Punto il fait damasin pour
A5 et 6
pas mal non plus un punto à VFE F3 c'est
un deuxième quasiment ouf 3 tout de
suite fe qu'elle allait prendre le 5
j'imagine seul coup mais il va jouer à
feu
alors il trouve cavalier prend sinon
après un deuxième pion tout simplement
lien qui va il n'y a pas de structure il
y a rien il fait tout refait un joli
suivi de tour F4 il va aller taper B4
comme ça
tu aurais fait c'est beau ça tape F6 ça
va en faire encore un de plus hein
il fait mal là il fait mal sur scène là
il s'est réveillé
et fou des trois bien joué force qui est
prend des trois pions prend des trois
et la finale très très facilement gagné
un Maxime
H7 en plus c'est ça
quand même alors pour HC par contourrage
intermédiaire toi recette tu reprends un
petit abandon
et oui ça fait mal tournage 6
et Maxime qui calcule un coup écart et
gokuge qui calcule un demi coup
il y a encore un peu d'activités c'est
pas si mal joué de la part de goût cash
mais ça va pas suffire mais bon c'était
un bon une bonne chance pratique qu'il a
pris quand même
envie de faire baquer j'essaye de lui
faire un compliment quand même
bah qui veut la câbler et c'est là où on
veut échanger toutes les pièces vous
voyez là c'est clairement un moment je
vous conseille de pas forcément faire
que des échanges mais ici on échange
tout en F5
et on gagne la finale de pion
ces trois bien joué il retire la pièce
active c'était facile mais ok
il a raison
c'est bien ce qu'il fait
le roi Maxime
et ça va être la pause après celle-là
possède
plus que la case B5 pour le cavalier
allez il faut abandonner gokash
il fait tourbé 7 tours B4 aussi abandon
également fallait pas faire roi
ok il a pris une petite chance là
Maxime vigilant bien sûr voir ses quatre
et qui reprend maki les 7 mois d'écart
et Maxime qui a été meilleur sur la fin
de ce segment qui au début
ça reprend dans 6 minutes 50 je propose
qu'on se refasse une petite pause
tout de suite
saviez-vous que vous pouvez pimenter vos
parties en ligne et vous analysez avec
des emoji il vous suffit de cliquer sur
l'icône emoji puis de sélectionner votre
emoji et de cliquer avec le bouton
gauche de la souris sur l'échiquier vous
pouvez choisir parmi une multitude de
notation de coûts d'animation
d'émoticônes et même vos personnalités
préférées du monde des échecs des
émoticônes et les emojis disparaîtront
au bout de quelques secondes en revanche
les notations de coûts les animations
spéciales restent sur l'échiquier
jusqu'à ce qu'elle soit effacées pour ce
faire il suffit de cliquer avec le
bouton gauche de la souris sur les mots
J ou de cliquer sur le bouton Tout
effacer
[Musique]
essayez tous et amusez-vous bien sur
Chess.com
[Musique]
ça reprend les amis on a du Bac qui va
qui va arriver il va être il va être de
retour il s'est fait dribbler par par là
par le mini break Baki
mais bon c'est pas très grave
seconde
donc ça ça repart avec un système de
Londres
qui est de retour
ça c'est la variante que je joue avec
les Blancs aussi
c'est le bon ordre de coup
parce que Maxime va montrer la
réputation de ta variante
il va partir pour le foie F5 bah qui
juste si si
je crois que c'est ça ouais avec du
c'est quoi trop un moment donné
Maxime qui réfléchit
si Google je peux nous montrer une autre
ouverture
très contente mais je crois que non pas
d'idée
le goût cash
et encore Maxime vous pouvez jouer le
blé français
le timing de A4 est très très mauvais
après dame B6 fallait peut-être tenter
d'un cadre pas trop comment prendre
l'avantage je suis un peu écoeuré
C4 un coup actif
pourquoi je joue en fait
c'est joli ouais
je sais pas quoi choisir petit rock
c'est 4 décath
des 5 suivi d'un B7
c'est vraiment très simple
le coup le plus simple bien joué et
cavalier prend G6 peut-être qu'il va les
prendre
mais ça va quand même oui ça va quand
même mais c'est plus avantage déjà
mais
il fatigue là ça se touche les yeux ça
va bâiller bientôt
dames
du B5 quand même non je vais faire dame
C4 à ce moment-là
mais tous les coups sont mauvais en fait
côté côté
les catastrophes
pour vous c'est 5 et sur quel point BK
il faut prendre F6 ok il avait pas
de vigilance
une perte de notre vigilance quand il y
a de tels coups
allez c'est ici qu'il faut montrer qu'on
est fort et trouver les bons coups c'est
le top pas mal
mais ça joue un peu pour gagner quand ça
devrait pas je suis pas sûr
après c'est du ou à échec j'ai
l'impression que c'est comme au rugby en
période de coupe du monde quand ça
envoie les ballons sur les ailes alors
que ça devrait il faut juste renvoyer au
pied et ça décide de jouer à la main qui
il y a pas
d'ailleurs il a peut-être loupé le tour
du monde
alors attention à tour des cinq prises
et 8
on perd complètement notre vigilance
elles sont trop décousues il va faire
dame
[Musique]
attention à pas s'ouvrir le roi enfin
elle était bien la dame en fait
j'aimerais bien qu'il joue plutôt pour
eux 5 fermer ce fou avec une dame en F7
je vais pour une tour en B5 là c'est on
sent qu'il va il y a il va y avoir du
Tour C4 bientôt
F3 d'ailleurs
j'ai proposé de la merde aussi
c'est
mais il y a pas un tour des deux là
pardon et eux c'est pas 5 on s'était
cloué pardon
G5 il veut 5 il veut ton cou essayer
d'échanger quelques pièces ça c'est bon
gros coup que j'aime bien là
il est parti faire les bordures hein bah
qui avec la dame
un très bon coup d'un meufc tour G5 il y
avait E5 attention sur E5 de pas faire
G6 on peut quand même
ça fait peur quand même
il y a encore
5 maintenant il aurait peut-être mieux
valu commencer par 5 en fait
c'est jouer beaucoup au hasard cette
partie
des deux côtés
ingénieux dame c'est ça je sais pas j'ai
l'impression que ça fait des trucs
parce qu'il renforce le roi adverse on
n'arrive pas à passer par derrière
c'est n'importe quoi
c'est n'importe quoi qui
est les yeux encore une fois notre
Maxime
il commençait possible face à de tels
coups
c'est n'importe quoi
la taille théorique sur ce fouet 4 jouer
par rapport contre
allez un petit cahier ou fout des trois
dessins avec des deux
oh il laisse fout des 6 ici mais c'est
moche qui va mieux cette
ils sont ils jouent plus aux échecs en
fait enfin je sais pas trop comment dire
alors évidemment par à coup des fois ils
font des supers séries de coup mais ils
sont plus dedans là
ouais ouais c'est
toutes les parties un peu comme ça
mais encore une fois c'est pas une
critique envers envers les joueurs c'est
le format qui veut ça
c'est normal quand les quand les scores
ont trop enflé c'est difficile c'est
tellement dur les échecs comme jeu ça a
tellement je te concentration ça demande
tellement d'efforts que quand le
sort du match est plus ou moins décidé
c'est c'est dur de de garder l'intensité
dans le jeu
c'est pour ça que vous voyez ces sautes
de concentration et c'est bizarre il
ils font partie inhérentes du format qui
fait la force aussi en de ce format qui
va donner une pièce sur le coup
[Musique]
je sais pas quoi dire c'est dur de
d'analyser là
qui délectons-nous
même c'est 5 d'ailleurs parce que c'est
5 qui va les prendre des six dames
prendre des six poubelles
il y a il y avait roi E7 qui protège la
dame et sur fousser quatre fois cinq et
cavalie F5 qui est en souffrance la case
5 qui est bien pour le fou
qui serait mieux en F3
6 quelque chose comme ça
que F les blancs vont suivre parfois des
seins et ce sera Maximin qui aura la
meilleure position donc c'est 5 fous ces
quatre bien joué du côté de Maxime
mais bon c'est dur de
dire Kevin
je sais plus quoi dire que au bout d'un
moment c'est match j'ai plus j'ai plus
les mots bon bah qui
F3 un coin intéressant voilà enfin qui
perd probablement il y a pas de mais ça
change le cours du jeu
ça c'est un coup qui me plaît
un joli coup effectivement
mais il a joué vite quand même Maxime
ça peut être catastrophique
mais bon
problème 5 puis on prend F5 d'un H4
attention quand même
ça m'aurait pris plus de temps que
Maxime pour calculer ce coup
peut-être du Dame des 7 après
il va jouer
mais pourquoi ne pourquoi jouer tour à 7
tempo et pas un coup comme par exemple
mais disons tout D8 autour 8
ça peut pas marcher ce qui fait mais
quoi que Romain il y a pion projet 2
tours quand j'ai deux dames prends un
machin F6 échec
ça doit être le coup le bon coup ou faut
prendre cette bien joué Maxime ok ça
c'est un bon
parce que si dam G3 il y a de la meuble
de la notice d'Alger 6 d'un projet 3
mais c'est normal ok ça se voit qu'il y
a rien qui va ton F6 ça a gagné
facilement aussi je pense elle a droit
et c'est ça
c'est n'importe quoi
on va pouvoir repasser à plus sept bah
qui je crois qu'on est en train de se
stabiliser sur cet écart de 6 à 8 points
est-ce que c'est marlou côté Maxime de
perdre du temps pour jouer de la meuf 3
pour faire durer la partie le plus
longtemps possible
je pense qu'il regarde dame G6 pour D6
F6
tours
avec avec puis on prend j'ai deux dame
et fin de la F3 et des perpettes
en tout cas ça fait ça fait cinq douze
ça fait plus 7
la bataille théorique là
tellement bien dans celle d'avant
pourquoi changer là on peut pas jouer
avec
ça c'est une ligne aussi non
ça clique un peu au hasard pas trop non
plus
il y a pas
d'âme des deux prises des deux qui est
prend des deux et abandon c'est une
pièce
[Musique]
et non en fait ça marche son truc ça
devait exister
ça doit être préparé OK
et nous ne connaissons pas nos chats
ignorants
mais ça avait l'air bien gagner pour les
Noirs ok si c'est bien pour les blancs
tout pas mal sauf que Maxime il clique
les bons coups là
et que même après coup franc C5 ici il
te reprend G7
[__]
tout de suite il va aller B8 ici
mais même cavalier prend alors
pourquoi pas jouer fou français 5
bien joué mais faut penser ça
et ça va pour oui tu veux dire que ça va
quand même
on peut pas aller sur la colonne F on va
jouer roi des 7 tours
un peu mieux pour les Noirs mais bon
c'est pas roi des 7 quand même ici
j'aime bien roi des 7 tours bien ton D8
mais ça va ce qu'il fait
ça sera suffisant
ah mais c'était joli tour des 8 parce
que l'idée c'était que sur Roissy 2 les
blancs pouvaient pas jouer tourbé un non
plus à cause de faux 4 il prend il
empêche la tour G1 de s'activer avec ce
tour d'éviter chaque intermédiaire
complètement le fouger 3 hein
parce que si je jouais petit rock
d'abord
donc ici il empêche complètement la tour
de sortir
vraiment jouer avec un pas
tu as fait pareil à cause des fous de
couleurs opposés mais je pense qu'il va
essayer de jouer cette idée quand même
ah de jouer G4 ici et de même acheter
c'est ça et de dire tu as pas ton fou je
ramène le roi et
oui oui c'est vrai que je pensais qu'il
voulait faire en fait depuis tout à
l'heure pour ça je suis capable en cas
de
j'étais curieux tu sais de savoir juste
les skis avec les fous de couleur
opposés tu peux faire juste la même en
fait
c'est par curiosité mais là
je pense que ça a pas tactiquement ça
allait
ça doit gagner non quand même
bon ça va gagner même si même si c'est
pas gagnant ça va gagner parce que là
pour défendre un truc pareil
c'est trop le prend pour un Belin
maintenant au bouquet c'est beaucoup
trop ça va être dur de jouer les
prochains les prochaines parties contre
lui
on le prend tellement pour un Belin
maintenant
espacés comme ça
le garder c'est ça la question
menace 3 6 ah oui ça a été loupé ça se
croit B5 joli roi B5 pour roi 6 ou des 5
et sur rois 6 ok pas sûr qu'il a gagné
mais il va monter le roi et sur ces 6 il
va il va sacrifier le fond en C8 ou quoi
ça doit gagner quand même après
le truc c'est que le roi va venir en F3
ouais ça va gagner en fait
attention sa menace il y a fou français
6e 3 ici qui gagne
aussi ça va gagner aussi mais prends ces
6 ça a gagné tout de suite
au 3 et feu F3 s'abandon
une position qui était probablement
gagnante mais
c'est trop facile
et ça fait de nouveau 8 points d'écarts
même si Maxime n'a pas beaucoup
d'intérêt
et le pire c'est que c'est déjà
quasiment mathématiquement terminé quoi
ce match c'est ouais c'est c'est ce
qu'on appelle une purge pour ceux qui
ont qui sont pas supporters
et pas que dans l'ouverture Baki
ce qui va jouer à 6 fou B6 ici
pourquoi tu joues et lui dit
il sait pas quoi faire là Maxime il est
pas bien
il est pas bien du tout là
ce qui regarde
c'est le 5
finalement
c'est horrible comme coup
il y a pire que se faire un marché
dessus en speechers mais bon c'est long
quand même
j'avais vu mais bon
cette ouverture Maxime tu as - 8 tu te
prends cette ouverture
c'est horrible tu as envie d'arrêter les
échecs là
je crois que tu as envie d'arrêter les
échecs à ce point
très très dur Maxime
ça prend des 5 fous prends des seins
mais oui tempo
disant le chat qu'il a l'air maigre là
google est-il un problème de santé
peut-être un problème d'eau
peut-être une infection alimentaire qui
attends il y a pas d'impro 5 ici
si on prend ton tour
ça fait plaisir d'avoir un petit coup
comme d'hab.5 ici dommage
c'est horrible il s'amuse Maxime
moi j'étais sur ça aussi personnellement
pendant que tu as
Maxime il m'a dit qu'il adorait
sacrifier les dames
merci au revoir alors j'ai une bonne
nouvelle pour kookash quand même c'est
la dernière partie en trois plus un
quand même qui va quand même la gagner
après pourquoi faire ça ça a pas
d'intérêt même si si
mais ta meuf 63
mais bon il y avait pas d'intérêt enfin
la position pourquoi après s'amuser
trois dettes ou c'est 5 vous prenez un
deux
et ciao et oui ok ouf
on va pouvoir faire une pause là et
c'est vrai que rester surtout parce que
le match n'est pas fini il y a que 9
points d'écart bah qui avant le dernier
segment voilà ça va être drôle quand
même le Bullet ok on arrive quand même
quoi qu'il arrive par contre c'est beau
au cœur un prédiction 100%. portant
quand même
voilà ça c'est faux c'est faux
évidemment
c'est faux ça peut pas 100% c'est beau
en fait même l'ordi ouais bon ok merci
au revoir dernière pause du coup
dernière pose baquet pour toi elle va
être courte en plus parce que tu as le
tu as du title bientôt
ça va être dur d'enchaîner mais
des échecs comme vos créateurs préférés
tels que blindstream Naka ou les soeurs
le programme de Community streamer de
chains.com est fait pour vous débutant
dans le streaming ou déjà expérimenté
peu importe c'est le moyen idéal pour
élargir votre audience vous connectant
votre compte à cheese.com et profiter de
la visibilité offerte alors d'autres
plateforme de jeu il vous suffit de
relier votre compte à
cheese.com/settings/ connectique
comme catégorie sur twitch et commencer
à streamer
d'une expérience sans publicité sur
chaise.com et apparaîtrez dans notre
liste de streamer en direct votre
profits.com affichera votre Street
twitch qui sera aussi mis en avant
durant vos parties enfin utiliser la
commande comédie streamer dans le chat
et faites grossir votre audience sans
plus attendre
[Musique]
ça repart les amis pour pour la fin de
ce match on va se délecter encore de
la compétition là des dernières parties
qui va bientôt revenir et qui va
repartir un petit peu avant comme je
vous disais il va jouer le title quand
même plus intéressant à mon avis que
cette fin de match on va pas
tourner autour du pot enfin de match qui
n'a plus de saveur ni d'enjeux
malheureusement
on est content la victoire de Maxime qui
va nous offrir quelques très très belles
passes d'armes
dans les dans les jours à venir
et j'ai envie de dire des des
cartes de finale contre ça rime puis
peut-être un magnifique demi-finale
à venir contre
icaru à caméra mais là pour ce premier
match
c'était
vraiment une formalité on voit que même
l'intelligence artificielle donne 100%
de chance de gagner qui se prend le
petit plateau si tu veux te faire une
petite pause avant si tu veux te faire
la petite pause avant le title bah qui
n'hésite pas à la vraiment je crois que
je viens avec vous regarder les bolotes
quand même joueur de Pelé F3
j'imagine que Maxime elle est noire
j'ai pas vérifié mais oui oui enfin
c'est ça se voit la position après j'ai
pas le cas les lots de gueule
je vais le trouver je suis pas sûr qu'il
soit nettement plus fort que moi en fait
en belette qui fait peur quand même
ah si il est 314
non mais je sais pas ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui je sais pas il y a des gens
qui sont mieux le connaître que nous qui
disent qu'il a l'air malade mais après
je vois pas trop c'est vrai qu'il a pas
l'air hyper bien c'est possible
on dit la l'air malade alors peut-être
oui peut-être il est juste malade ça
c'est possible
pour parce que moi j'ai joué une fois
avec une intoxication alimentaire c'est
horrible
tout à l'heure
si c'est son niveau habituel
là c'est mathématiquement fini parce que
normalement c'est neuf dix party max en
belette si Maxime il déco où il fait une
dinguerie sur la cam et tout il peut se
faire exclure non alors là si tout d'un
coup il se lève il enlève son calcul tu
vois un peu comme à Ino speed là tu sais
pas si tu as vu la vidéo sur Twitter
high show speed
comme ça ouais si tout d'un coup il se
lève machin qu'il a la braguette du
machin qui s'ouvre et tout ouais sur un
truc comme ça ça peut encore perdre
on est loin du 100% là
d'ailleurs il s'est pas fait ban
finalement suite à ça speed
mais en fait je savais pas qui c'était
avant de voir son nom
ça m'intéresse pas trop
mais c'est beau ensuite c'est beau parce
qu'il a dit qu'il avait pas fait exprès
non non c'est 100% pas exprès ça ça se
voit que dès que ça arrive il suit
instantanément il en sur total quoi
non non c'était vraiment pas exprès mais
c'est beau voilà ça fait mal de voir les
pions pendant jouer par donner un mot
et oui d'un meuf 5 G6 d'un E5 et je
crois que datinko est perdu
tu as vu comment j'arrive
à changer le sujet
alors que c'est possible
mais c'est Punto aussi
ça c'est beau ça si ça passe waouh
ça c'était un enchaînement de Google
s'il avait joué le match à son niveau
réel aujourd'hui gokash
Ian
j'imagine ça pourrait
mais là il y a une nouvelle sortie à la
fin de l'année
il y a encore un livre qui sort
il va falloir mettre de la caillasse de
côté pour acheter tout ça mais
normalement il sera pas cher celui-là
mais il est très beau je l'ai lu c'est
pour te dire
17 cavalier 5 échec ok maintenant il va
il va beaucoup te plaire parce que c'est
un almana c'est tous les jours un truc à
apprendre chaque jour
et c'est vraiment intéressant c'est pour
tout niveau là vraiment mais il y a des
choses vraiment très fin tout le monde
peut apprendre
ok il va j'espère que tu viendras à la
maison passer pour faire les dédicaces
pour le cadeau
pour cadeau de Noël ou Nouvel An c'est
pour ces effets spécialement pour les
cadeaux de Noël et Nouvel An donc
j'espère que tu seras là
maintenant
c'est vrai tu es pas bien
[Rires]
avec son truc
là c'est fini ouais
bah il y a des parties d'aujourd'hui qui
vont rentrer dans le cahier de Kiev
c'est sûr plus on
c'est vraiment
dur pour
mais on a vu on a vu la fulgurance le
tour C5 te reprend des 5 H6 sur la
partie d'avant
il y a une fulgurance
enfin je dirais
Maxime je pense que juste fermer le vélo
de chasse comme en fait maintenant
ah bah ouais
toujours pareil
ça va être dur de se concentrer pour le
pour le title
je sais Baki ce sera un exploit si tu
réussissais à mettre des puntos après je
suis inscrit
ça c'est bon
c'est déjà bien
en plus
pour le premier parti du tournoi je suis
parti je me suis levé ce matin à 6h50
j'avais le train avec Sofia
à 8h20
midi 20 c'est juste ce temps de manger
lancer le live ça suit un peu ici aussi
mais Sofia adore le train c'est la
première fois qu'on prenait le train
elle a kiffé elle est très heureuse dans
le train
jusqu'à maintenant c'est son moyen de
locomotion préféré là est très très
heureuse elle regarde par la fenêtre
elle joue sur la table elle adore
Maxime qui envoie son roi aussi là
pas sûr que ça forme
ça va passer
dans les pions de Maxime
[Musique]
maintenant
3 mais d'ailleurs il a sué
il est monté sur scène il a sué
on comprend pas un coup même si c'est du
Bullet normalement on comprend
un coup
en plus ouais
au lieu de jouer le title
Maxime quand même je suis content il est
resté bien concentré il m'a un gros
score c'est bien
là il se déconcentrer quand même un peu
sur certaines portions du 3 + 5 même du
5 mais moins qu'à son habitude
ouais dès qu'il a vu que pendant 5 10
minutes il jouait un peu à côté il est
revenu dans les game ah ouais il est
revenu plus plus rapidement
qu'habituellement
il est loin d'être à son niveau max mais
il est tout de même assez solide
par rapport au corps il aurait il aurait
pu un peu ce
mais il le fait pas ici il se détache
pas du tout quoi
mais il se détache pas du match
par contre il va pas être bien il va pas
pouvoir jouer le title Maxime
et non
mais ils étaient censés jouer lundi
il y a de la fulgurance
bon après c'est pas super
[Musique]
dame et d'un machka
ça fait 18
je risque de louper le 20e Punto
dommage
ouais mais c'est loin je trouve ce match
ça devient vraiment longuet
bon
on va voir le prochain contre Sarine on
va voir si il arrive à gagner facilement
à plus serré contre Sarine ça c'est sûr
[Musique]
qui cherche un gain là mais il y a pas
vraiment
fait F5 j'aime pas trop
pas si mal mais bon
ça part
à 5 à 3 à 4 pouces moi tout ça Maxime
[Musique]
très très solide
j'aimerais même pleutre
et ouais mais il risque de se faire
punir sur les cases noires
de l'autre côté avec du B4 mais ça va
pas être facile hein dur à jouer sans
Bullet
IR comme ça avec le roi sa roi des 7
c'est pas mal pour cavalier 5 rois et 7
et roi B8 un peu à l'instar d'Ali raisin
contraire d'Oche championnat d'Europe
2021 mais ouais il se fait les cases
noires il a dû apprendre sur les parties
de Mazet finalement
c'est la deuxième fois pendant ce
speechestre
bravo il a il a les rêves
Maxime qui va tenter d'ouvrir avec eux 5
ça ça le change hein
pourquoi pas
Maxime qui défend pour le moment
après
tu auras 5 c'est peut-être une bonne
nouvelle à
ah oui parce que cavalier prend à 6 et
tu prends ok il y a eu un bon
enchaînement là côté gauche quand même
ça casse pas trois patins
j'ai envie de dire c'est pas ça qui va
le
Maxime qui donne un punto
pas grand chose cette fois
pour s'amuser bah qui pour s'amuser
quand même pas mal
il est un peu une position comme il a eu
contre justement
tu es bien inscrit
je suis inscrit
d'ailleurs j'ai un classement
cataclysmique là on joue à 2803
est-ce que je vais abandonner le match
ou pas c'est un peu la dernière question
qui se pose tu as le droit d'abandonner
à 10 minutes de la fin
ça c'est beau pour aller gagner le title
dans la foulée je sais pas si il va le
faire
j'ai fait n'importe quoi
Brad micro côté souris je suis pas bien
si tu t'es trompé de côté
toujours faire attention à son de scène
OK
mais il faut que je retire le son non je
vais je vais je vais me mute t'inquiète
pas
comme ça je reste sur discord et on
reste comme ça on reste dans la pelle et
après il reste une minute on peut finir
cette game
en plus c'est une jolie attaque là
de part et d'autre
si c'est un médecin qui a tout rêve 7
qui défend encore
enfin c'est dur à jouer ces positions de
lettres là Maxime qui fait un petit
signe de dépit
c'est quoi ce croquet sur cavalier
prendre à ma 4 il veut quoi
dans ma carte d'investisseur
mais Maxime aussi
c'était contre échec
est-ce que tu as participé
allez je te mute on te récupère
je sais pas si ça va jouer jusqu'au bout
côté
c'est une jolie partie là à l'instant
malheureusement qui compte pour pour du
beurre
attendez
OK
complexe
c'est une petite tactique trouvée par
Google
Maxime qui mène 19 61 c'est énorme comme
c'est un score absolument énorme on
espère que vous cache abandonne la
diminue de la fin parce que c'est après
des fois les joueurs oublient
d'abandonner
c'est un peu une purge là de terminer le
match
pour tout le monde
pour Maxime pour nous pour vous
une idée sur les sur les damages de
d'avoir partir avec le roi
c'est ce qui fait
c'est ce qu'il fait
jeter un œil
normalement il doit
bien nous abandonner le match
pour récupérer le cavalier derrière et
tenir le pion G6
il est obligé de faire ça et
malheureusement la Maximy a plus
d'attaque
il doit être maintenant ici
ça ça doit être mat
parce que
on n'arrive pas à sortir en fait
Maxime qui abandonne voir si Google joue
jusqu'au bout et oui il abandonne pas le
match ils oublient en fait généralement
qui peuvent Quick
ça va jouer jusqu'au bout
on voit Baki concentré
peut jeter un œil à la partie de Baki si
vous voulez aussi
j'imagine que ça vous intéresse aussi
donc on peut vous faire plaisir et jeter
un petit œil
par curiosité
il y a plus d'enjeux maintenant dans le
title vu que ce match est plié déjà
depuis
je dirais trois heures en fait
avec les Blancs qui a une finale
correcte
on va retourner sur Maxime et on ira
jetait un oeil
c'était pas attendu un tel écarme après
le match a très mal commencé avec un
missclic pour pour goûter
un peu plus tard dans le match il est il
est tombé à la pendule aussi de manière
un peu un peu bête
c'est pas trop pourquoi ou comment il
était en si mauvaise forme mais en tout
cas
c'était pas son jour très clairement
ce n'était clairement pas son jour
quelqu'un dans le chat qui semblait
malade ça après j'en sais rien il
faudrait écouter les interviews d'après
match
quoi qu'il en soit ça nous a pas offert
un beau duel
pas pu défendre ses chances
comme on l'aurait souhaité
et là il abandonne
c'est le 20e point pour pour Maxime je
suppose
on va voir si ça a gagné côté Baki
ça a l'air de bien se passer là pour
Baki
qui a un pion de plus
et des pions passés là-bas
normalement il va faire ses 5 et
cavaliers B4 il commence par cavalier 5
et à 3 il veut bloquer le cavalier
là il y a encore H6 cavalier ici H5
cavalier 5 à et G6 c'est ça le problème
bah qui devrait remporter cette première
partie
elle va quand même aller prendre à 7
et revenir avec le rond des 4
et repasser et repasser comme ça ouais
fuite
bien joué pour visser la case de 5
et maintenant c'est 5 et cavaliers ah
ouais H4 même plus besoin de cavalier 5
on gagne les cases petit à petit côté
blanc et on va pouvoir envoyer les trois
mobylettes
il y en a un peu trop la démobilette
un peu trop de mobylette à arrêter
ouais et maintenant c'est cette mobile
là
qui va au bout
mais ça va faire le point pour pour
Étienne voilà dames
et le mat
sous nos yeux ébahis c'est gagné pour
baquet on va voir si Maxime a réussi à
gagner il y a une déco je crois ou un
problème pour Google
ça fait 21 pour Maxime
et point qui qui s'enchaînent
les 14 points d'écart il reste encore 3
minutes à jouer peut-être deux parties
c'est dur
c'est très dur
on va récupérer
bien joué
on a vu ta game
Maxime qui a fait enfler le score qui
pendant que tu étais là pendant que tu
étais au title
14 points d'écart maintenant
on va bientôt te retrouver parce qu'il
reste plus que deux parties dans le
match
OK
on a suivi à la fin de ta partie
d'ailleurs on a décidé en fait d'aller
voir ta finale qui nous semblait plus
intéressante
j'ai un peu SUV quand même dans cette
finale
j'ai un peu plus tard
la technique en finale de cavalier
dans ce match
il a pas été récupéré ses 6 tout de
suite Maxime il veut mater en fait
aujourd'hui
je vais aller la chercher
les amis il va nous rester une partie
derrière et après donc je ferai le raid
et on rejoindra le backy National
je peux pas faire de raid bon bah je
vous mettrai le lien
et vous viendrez retrouver le bikini
national
à moins que que la partie dure encore 30
secondes
attention
assez complexe
tu vas tenter un C4
c'est 6
à 5 dame G2
ah il reste juste du temps pour en faire
une dernière à la seconde près on rate
la partie de Baki
pas de bol ça réjouit trois quatre
secondes de plus
n'aurait pu aller voir directement la
partie de backi mais non il y en a
encore une dernière pour être vraiment
bien sûr
parce que là on est pas bien sûr de qui
est le plus fort encore
il faut avoir une dernière
ouais ouais très très belle partie de
très très beau match de Maxime
bah match
j'arrive pas à voilà on n'arrive pas à
comprendre pour écouter les l'interview
d'après match de gokash on n'arrive pas
à trop à comprendre une telle différence
de niveau on sait que Maxime est plus
fort mais tellement plus fort
ça reste ça reste étonnant il y a pas
qu'il prend eux
[Musique]
la victoire de Maxime qui nous étonne
c'est comment il a gagné
il a complètement raté la maxime
par pur bol
et sur ta mh6 je sais pas
je sais pas ce qu'il a ici
en tout cas Maxime qui aura représenté
avec le maillot bled stream
et ça ça fait plaisir
on va voir ce qui réussit à nous faire
notre notre mvl nous notre mvl ou je
sais pas trop comment l'appeler
on va voir ce qui est réussi à nous
faire
c'est un peu un pion des cars maintenant
à faire tourner la finale avec cavalier
3 il y a tout rêve de c'est bien joué
il devrait la perdre celle-là Maxime
pour terminer
tu as bien fait de jouer jusqu'au bout
Maxime qui monte le roi
il commence par cavalier
ah ok
il abandonne et donc le score final 21,5
merci à tous d'avoir suivi ce match en
notre compagnie et nous vous pouvez nous
suivre je peux pas faire le raid comme
je vous disais mais il y a quelqu'un qui
va vous mettre le lien dans le chat et
vous allez pouvoir retrouver Baki qui va
jouer son title merci à tous ciao ciao à
bientôt pour la suite du Spee